bien mesdames et messieurs bonsoir notre
commission d'enquête chargé d'établir
les raisons de la perte de souveraineté
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
a le plaisir de recevoir ce soir la
barbara Pompili
chers collègues nous vous remercions
d'avoir répondu favorablement à notre
invitation afin de nous faire part de
vos analyses et répondre à nos questions
notre intérêt porte sur la période au
cours de laquelle vous avez exercé des
fonctions de ministre de la transition
écologique lors des deux dernières
années du précédent quinquennat qui
s'est achevé en 2022 vous attributions
étaient alors très étendue puisque outre
le développement durable l'environnement
et l'énergie et le climat
entrer dans le champ de vos attributions
les domaines des transports de
l'équipement du logement et de
l'urbanisme les auditions organisées par
la Commission ont d'ailleurs montré la
forte imbrication de ces différents
secteurs au sein des stratégies
énergétiques au titre de l'énergie du
climat vous étiez chargé d'élaborer et
de mettre en œuvre la politique de
l'énergie je cite afin notamment
d'assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement fin de citation vous
étiez également conjointement avec le
ministre de l'Économie compétente pour
la politique des matières premières et
des mines en ce qui concerne les
matières énergétiques au titre de
l’environnement vous aviez compétences
en matière de sûreté nucléaire
vous avez porté la loi du 22 août 2021
portant lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et renforcement de la
résilience face à ses effets qui dans le
domaine qui intéresse la commission
d'enquête réforme le code minier
introduit diverses dispositions pour
favoriser le développement des énergies
renouvelables et maîtriser la
consommation d'énergie mais ne consacre
pratiquement aucun article nucléaire à
l'exception semble-t-il d'un article
introduit à l'initiative du Sénat
subordonnant la fermeture de réacteurs à
des objectifs de sécurité
d'approvisionnement et de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
concomitamment le plan national de
relance et de résilience reposant au
moins pour partie sur des financements
européens à programmé des
investissements de plusieurs milliards
d'euros en faveur de la rénovation
énergétique de la décarbonation de
l'industrie des mobilités et des
technologies vertes je précise que le
décret ayant abrogé l'autorisation
d'exploiter la centrale nucléaire de
Fessenheim a été pris quelques mois
avant votre entrée en fonction nous
entendrons d'ailleurs prochainement la
première ministre Madame Elisabeth borne
qui vous avait précédé dans l'exercice
de ces fonctions enfin dernier point qui
me paraît utile d'évoquer dans le cadre
de ce propos introductif la publication
des scénarios du RTE future énergétique
2050 sur lesquels vous aviez été
auditionné le 26 octobre 2021 par la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire de notre
assemblée commission que vous aviez
d'ailleurs présenté au cours de du début
de la précédente législature
au cours de cette audition les scénarios
alternatifs de nigawatts qui envisage un
recours massif aux ENR sans aucun apport
du nucléaire ont été cités comme s'il
fournissaient un éclairage en
contrepoint
avant de vous donner la parole madame la
ministre il me revient d'appliquer
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires que vous
commandez bien puisque vous avez
vous-même présider une commission
d'enquête prescrivant que les personnes
auditionnées par une commission
d'enquête doivent prêter serment je vous
demande donc dès lors de bien vouloir
lever la main droite et dire je le jure
madame la ministre je vous laisse donc
la parole pour un propos introductif
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur chers collègues alors tout
d'abord je rectifie je n'étais pas
présidente de la commission d'enquête
j'étais rapporteur et donc je n'avais
pas à faire ce devoir de tout président
de commission d'enquête et de demander à
chacun de de prêter serment
je suis heureuse de pouvoir m'exprimer
devant cette commission pour expliquer
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé pendant
ces deux années où j'ai été aux manettes
de ce très très grand ministère de la
transition écologique qui effectivement
était un ministère qui avait un
périmètre très large il y avait été
notamment ajouté
contrairement à ce que au portefeuille
de mes prédécesseurs le logement qui a
été je crois à un ajout très intéressant
parce que il a permis de rapprocher les
les administrations de ces deux
ministères qui étaient déjà proches en
soi mais qui ont permis au ministère du
Logement de plus s'orienter sur les
questions énergétiques justement
notamment sur la rénovation thermique
qui a fait l'objet de nombreuses mesures
qui ont été adoptées notamment dans la
loi climat et résilience quand j'arrive
aux manettes de ce ministère il faut
bien avoir en tête que beaucoup de
choses ont évolué sur les questions
énergétiques très récemment
outre la loi de transition énergétique
et sur la croissance verte qui avait
donné une impulsion finalement il y a
pas si longtemps que ça puisqu'on était
en 2015
et là moi quand j'arrive on est en 2020
donc 5 ans avant nous avons une loi qui
a mis en place ce qu'on appelle la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
et donc il y a lancé une forme de
dynamique suite à cette loi juste après
l'accord de Paris a donné des objectifs
ambitieux pour réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et
ensuite nous avons un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont prises et qui sont des
mesures que je me dois moi de prendre en
compte quand j'arrive à ce ministère
notamment la loi énergie climat de 2019
qui est une loi qui a été portée par un
de mes prédécesseurs Nicolas Hulot et
qui est une loi qui notamment définie un
objectif de neutralité carbone en 2050
donc toujours dans la suite de l'accord
de Paris et une loi qui met en place un
certain nombre de mesures un petit peu
emblématiques on a beaucoup parlé de la
fin des centrales à charbon mais il y
avait aussi l'arrêt de la
commercialisation des véhicules
thermiques en 2040 ce qui était une
révolution à l'époque quand on voit ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
le passage à 2035 qui a été voté au
Parlement européen on voit que les
choses avancent vite
et c'est ça mon point les choses
avancées vite
dans on va dire les intentions mais on
avait un vrai sujet de mise en oeuvre et
on avait un vrai sujet de d'organisation
de tout le monde pour tenir les
objectifs ambitieux qui avaient été
inscrit dans les différents dans les
différentes étapes que que je vous que
je vous ai rappelé et
je crois que le premier point qui était
important pour essayer de réussir cette
mise en oeuvre c'était d'essayer de
comprendre pourquoi on avait du mal à
mettre en oeuvre les objectifs et
la première raison selon moi pour
laquelle on avait du mal à
[Musique]
à tenir ses objectifs c'est parce que
en fait on avait du mal à accepter
l'idée qu'il fallait radicalement faire
évoluer notre politique énergétique
quand on a la conscience qu'on doit
évoluer on le fait on le fait vite on le
fait bien y compris en France et je me
rappelle
j'étais toute petite mais je me rappelle
du lancement du Plan Mesmer le plan
Messmer c'est assez intéressant de
revoir la manière dont il a été lancé
puisque à l'époque on était dans un
moment de crise de crise énergétique la
fameuse crise pétrolière qui avait donné
lieu à un certain nombre de de
restriction dont que je ne vais pas vous
rappeler que tout le monde connaît mais
quand ça a été annoncé
il a été décidé un plan qui reposait sur
trois piliers et ces trois piliers
c'était la sobriété énergétique déjà à
l'époque on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a
des idées vous connaissez le sujet
l'efficacité énergétique et le
déploiement d'une nouvelle
technologie de production énergétique
qui était le nucléaire et donc ça a été
le lancement du Plan nucléaire qui a
permis de d'installer des centrales
nucléaires sur tout le territoire
français en finalement très peu de temps
puisque je rappelle que l'immense
majorité des centrales qui ont été
construites sur notre territoire ont été
construites en une décennie
et après quelques-unes jusque 1997
donc
à l'époque on avait une vision claire je
crois que ce qui manquait jusqu'à
février 2022
c'est l'exposition d'une vision claire
de ce qu'on voulait faire en termes de
politique énergétique et à partir du
moment où on n'avait pas une vision
claire un elle n'était pas portée
politiquement deux elle n'était pas
suivie des faits par les différentes
filières qui du coup étaient dans une
position d'attente étroite du coup on
prenait du retard et donc on rendait
impossible des objectifs qui disant
avant était possible à une époque je me
suis exprimée tout le monde connaissait
les idées que je portais puisqu'il y
avait un débat sur les différents sur
les différents types d'énergie moi je
portais des idées qui étaient plutôt des
idées pour tendre vers le 100% d'énergie
renouvelable en 2025 en 2050 pardon 100%
soyons
si on modeste 100% d'énergie
renouvelable en 2050
je prétends et je j'insiste sur ce point
que il y a 10 ans de cela c'était
possible c'était réalisable à partir du
moment où on respectait les objectifs
qu'on s'était nous-mêmes à signer y
compris d'ailleurs dans la configuration
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui d'une
accélération du besoin d'électricité
dans notre pays
pour cela il aurait fallu que tous les
acteurs s'alignent sur cette sur cette
volonté or ce que l'on peut voir c'est
que nous avions un débat public
est-ce que je vais le dire comme ça
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
qui était malheureusement
biaisé du fait du positionnement
très antagoniste de ceux qui défendaient
d'un côté les énergies renouvelables et
de ceux qui défendaient de l'autre côté
l'énergie nucléaire
dès le départ et je pense que c'est un
des péchés
originels de notre politique énergétique
ceux qui défendaient les énergies
renouvelables étaient des militants
écologistes l'immense majorité là je
parle en grande masse vous trouverez des
exceptions sur tout était des militants
écologistes et les militants écologistes
étaient historiquement anti-nucléaire
pour de très bonnes raisons que je ne
renierai pas
dès lors
tous ceux qui défendaient le nucléaire
ont considéré
à cause de cette positionnement de
départ des personnes qui défendaient de
renouvelables qui étaient en nucléaire
que le renouvelable s'opposé que
l'énergie renouvelable dans son ensemble
dans toutes les énergies renouvelables
s'opposer au nucléaire et que donc le
développement des énergies renouvelables
deviennent deviendrait une menace pour
l'énergie nucléaire je peux vous dire
pour l'avoir vécu à de nombreux niveaux
aux différentes responsabilités que j'ai
exercées y compris bien avant d'être
ministre notamment quand j'étais
président de la commission du
développement durable quand j'ai été
rapporteur de commission d'enquête sur
la sûreté nucléaire cette antagonisme et
cette se positionnement de ceux qui
défendent l'énergie nucléaire en défense
face aux énergies renouvelables étaient
flagrant et à partir de ce moment là
toutes les avancées possibles dans les
énergies renouvelables étaient freinées
à cause de cette de ce de cette
antagonisme
à partir de ce moment là
y compris nos grands opérateurs et le
plus grand d'entre eux le plus important
d'entre eux EDF
EDF lui-même n'a pas fait beaucoup
d'efforts et je le dis sous serment n'a
pas fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour développer les énergies
renouvelables à la vitesse qui était
prévue par la loi transition énergétique
et de la croissance verte et par la PPE
ils ont fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
développer les renouvelables en dehors
de la France en dehors de l'hexagone
mais
au sein de l'Hexagone
je prétends qu'ils n'ont pas fait les
efforts qu'ils auraient pu faire pour
atteindre les objectifs pourquoi parce
que EDF a toujours considéré comme
prioritaire le développement et le
maintien de l'énergie nucléaire
d'autres opérateurs se sont engagés dans
le développement des renouvelables
évidemment mais
clairement
parce que il fallait sauver le soldat
nucléaire on n'a pas fait tous les
efforts puisque il y a eu des relais des
relais au niveau des différents
gouvernements au niveau en fait à toutes
les strates c'est pour ça que c'est très
compliqué de trouver des responsabilités
il y a eu des relais un peu partout pour
au minimum faire de la résistance
passive sur le développement des
renouvelables je pourrais vous en dire
un peu plus là dessus parce que le
développement aussi d'associations de
défense des paysages n'est pas étrangère
à tout ça non plus
à partir de ce moment-là au moment où
j'arrive à mon ministère pour revenir au
moment qui nous occupe au moment où
j'arrive à mon ministère il est une
évidence que nous ne tiendrons pas les
objectifs un de mes prédécesseurs
Nicolas Hulot a déjà dû rectifier le tir
sur le mix énergétique qui était prévu
au départ et a dû faire une annonce pour
repousser de 50% de la part du nucléaire
de 2025 à 2035
j'arrive aussi juste au moment où la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
vient de rendre ses 149 propositions
puisque j'arrive une semaine après la
réception à l'Elysée des membres de la
Convention citoyenne pour le climat je
sais que je vais être en charge et que
ça va prendre une des grosses parties de
mon de ma mission d'une loi qui aura
pour vocation de transcrire une bonne
partie des
mesures proposées par la Convention
citoyenne dont des mesures évidemment
sur le développement des énergies
renouvelables sur l'efficacité
énergétique etc
moi je me sentais un peu les mains pas
libres tant qu'on n'avait pas
soldé un peu ce débat sur
l'opposition entre le renouvelable et
les nucléaire je m'apesantis dessus
parce que pour moi ça a été vraiment
quelque chose qui a été un espèce de fil
vert de fil rouge comme vous voulez
pendant tout l'exercice de mes
responsabilités pour pouvoir solder cela
il fallait réussir à sortir des idées
reçues des uns et des autres
d'abord il fallait prouver
une bonne fois pour toute que si on
voulait un mix à 100% renouvelable
c'était possible mais prouver que
c'était possible mais dans un certain en
respectant un certain nombre de
conditions
là Ie l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie et RTE ont rendu un rapport
mon rendu un rapport au début de 2021
février 2021 de mémoire je pourrais vous
donner la date exacte qui était un
rapport que nous avions commandé
justement pour établir cette possibilité
ce rapport a eu juste le mérite de dire
oui c'est possible d'atteindre un mix à
2050 100% renouvelable dans notre pays
mais
pour arriver à cela il va falloir
respecter un certain nombre de de
d'étapes qui sont des étapes assez
lourdes et assez complexes
ça c'était juste pour que entre
guillemets le monde du nucléaire arrête
de dire que c'était pas possible donc ça
maintenant nous avons des experts qui
nous disent que c'est possible une fois
qu'on a eu ça on a pu passer à l'étape
suivante qui était une commande qui
avait été faite par ma prédécesseur
Elisabeth borne en plein accord avec
moi-même quand j'étais président de la
commission du développement durable nous
avions eu l'occasion d'en échanger une
commande qui avait été faite à RTE de
nous proposer des scénarios qui étaient
des scénarios donc faisable à 2050 de
mix électrique et ce qui était
intéressant dans le travail qui était
demandé à RTE c'était de de le faire de
manière complètement des passionnée
complètement techniques en disant voilà
pour arriver à la neutralité carbone en
2050 quels sont les scénarios
électriques là on parle que de
l'électricité qui peuvent être mis sur
la table quels sont leurs avantages
quels sont leurs inconvénients avec plus
ou moins de renouvelables dans les
scénario plus ou moins de nucléaires
selon les scénarios et deux scénarios
extrêmes l'un avec 100% de renouvelables
et l'autre avec alors 100% nucléaire ça
n'existe pas mais avec le maximum
possible de centrale nucléaire
c'est-à-dire en poussant la durée de vie
des centrales actuels le plus possible
et en construisant le plus possible de
réacteurs dans le temps qui nous est
donné c'est à dire entre maintenant et
RTE a sorti ces
scénarios en octobre 2021
donc une fois que la loi
que la loi
climat et résilience était déjà sortie
ce qui explique aussi que maintenant on
est un certain nombre de mesures à
prendre pour compléter la loi climat et
résilience ces scénarios ont fait
l'objet de plus de deux ans de travail
on fait l'objet je crois de 4000
contributions donc on est sur quelque
chose qui enfin est une base sur sur
laquelle j'insiste à la lecture de ce
résumé à tout le monde parce que il est
très très facile à lire il est très
simple il est et il est évident sur la
situation de la France telle qu'elle
était à ce moment-là et des possibilités
que nous avions et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que justement là ça
nous dit pas vous êtes coincé vous
n'avez qu'une seule solution non
c'est une aide à la décision des
décideurs publics et notamment des
gouvernements et notamment des
présidents de la République pour leur
dire voilà vous avez six possibilités à
vous de faire le choix à vous de choisir
laquelle vous paraît la plus acceptable
en revanche ce qui était intéressant
aussi de voir dans ces scénarios c'est
qu'il y avait des constantes dans tous
les dans tous les scénarios de RTE vous
avez deux constantes la première c'est
que il planifie une augmentation forte
du besoin en électricité dans les années
à venir
et donc il en tient compte dans ces
scénarios et le deuxième non il y en a
trois pardon on est constante la
deuxième constante c'est que quel que
soit le scénario y compris ceux avec
beaucoup de nucléaires il va y avoir
besoin de développer beaucoup les
énergies renouvelables
et la troisième constante c'est que on y
arrivera pas quel que soit le scénario
si on fait pas de gros efforts
d'économie d'énergie
une fois qu'on a dit ça
moi j'avais une feuille de route qui
était beaucoup plus facile à gérer parce
que enfin on avait la possibilité de
passer au-delà des guéguères pardon du
terme entre les pros et les Antilles
tout moi je faisais partie d'un clan
donc je l'assume complètement sauf que
là maintenant
dans un dans une période complexe que
nous vivons on ne peut plus se fonder
uniquement sur la manière dont on voit
les choses mais se fonder sur la réalité
et là on avait une base de réalité il y
avait d'autres scénarios vous avez
mentionné monsieur le Président le
scénario Negawatt qui est un scénario
intéressant qui part sur un certain
nombre de postulats un peu différents et
qui postulent qui travaille beaucoup sur
un scénario à 100% énergies renouvelable
mais j'ai eu l'occasion d'en discuter
avec avec eux leur scénarios est un
scénario à regarder comme les autres
sauf que ils se fonde du coup sur le
fait de prolonger très très très très
longtemps les centrales existantes et
dont on voit aujourd'hui à quel point il
y a des problèmes d'entretien donc je
voulais vraiment insister beaucoup dans
mon propos liminaire sur
ce moment qui a été un moment pour moi
bascule dans la politique énergétique de
notre pays pourquoi il a été bascule
parce qu'à partir de ce moment-là en
tout cas dans la tête du gouvernement
dans la tête du pré je ne dirais pas ce
qui se passe dans la tête du
gouvernement ou du président de la
République mais en tout cas dans les
discussions que nous avons eu
c'en était fini des tergiversations on
savait où on voulait aller et on savait
comment il fallait lancer les choses et
donc tout a suivi ensuite le discours de
Belfort est un discours dont je
considère moi alors ça a surpris des
gens parce que c'est ce qu'on retient de
ce discours c'est le fait qu'on ait
lancé des nouvelles paires de père
mais ce que moi je retiens de ce
discours pour l'avoir vécu dans la dans
ma chair c'est que enfin on débloque sur
les énergies renouvelables que enfin on
a une vraie direction sur les énergies
renouvelables et donc tout suit derrière
c'est à dire que on met les
administrations en ordre de marche on
met des sur les collectivités on avait
déjà avancé dans la loi climat
résilience mais on met en sorte de de
donner des outils à tout le monde pour y
arriver on fait on met la filière aussi
en obligation de de respecter un certain
nombre de règles plus précise plus
complexe on a un plan qui avait été
défini sur justement le développement
de l'éolien one short puisque on voit
bien que il y avait des soucis sur le
développement de l'éolien haunshore donc
il y a toute une charte qui a été
travaillée avec la filière on met en
place un plan de développement de
l'éolien offshore on met en place aussi
un grand plan de développement du
du photovoltaïque mais aussi d'autres
sources de renouvelables non électriques
comme par exemple la méthanisation les
certificats de biogaz sont une grande
avancée notamment qui a été mise en
place dans la loi de climat résilience
l'énergie la politique énergétique ça ne
peut pas se faire sans aussi maintenant
une vraie planification
là aussi quand je suis arrivé il y avait
un objectif qui était un objectif que
nous avions décidé nous en tant que
député et je suis très fière d'avoir
porté cela qui avait été mis dans la loi
énergique climat qui était le fait que
la PPE ne serait plus une PPE venue d'en
haut de l'administration ce serait une
PPE qui serait votée
au Parlement sur la base des scénarios
maintenant que nous avons qui pourront
éclairer la PPE mais donc la prochaine
PPE qui va être votée dans une loi cette
année sera une loi et ça c'est quelque
chose que je considère très important
parce que elle passe enfin devant le
Parlement
enfin on a besoin aussi de mise en œuvre
sur le terrain
on a vu aujourd'hui on a vu que la mise
en place de la transition énergétique
est une mise en place qui peut
rencontrer beaucoup de d'obstacles que
ce soit des obstacles faiblementaires
mais aussi des obstacles du
à certainement une insuffisance
d'associations des citoyens
d'associations des parties prenantes et
donc la mise en place d'une
planification était absolument
nécessaire elle ne pouvait pas se faire
au niveau du ministère de l'écologie
parce que une la transition écologique
en fait à une dimension qui est très
transversale et donc il fallait qu'elle
se place au niveau du Premier ministre
de la première ministre et c'est ce qui
a été fait avec la mise en place du sgpe
donc on verra ce qu'il advient de la
mise en oeuvre par le biais de cette
planification mais en tout cas les
jalons sont posés et je pense que
c'était très important et pour terminer
mon propos liminaire pour ne pas être
trop longue il manquait une
branche à cette politique globale
puisque je vous rappelle que le discours
de Belfort qui donne la direction
politique enfin vraiment de ce qu'on
veut faire
elle ce discours repose sur trois
piliers le premier pilier c'est la
renaissance de de réacteurs nucléaires
le deuxième pilier c'est le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et le troisième pilier c'est la baisse
de la demande d'énergie de d'énergie oui
donc la sobriété énergétique ce point là
était un point qui était assez difficile
à faire rentrer dans les mœurs c'est
marrant parce que je vous l'ai dit on en
parlait déjà dans le plan Messmer mais
il y avait une difficulté à faire entrer
ça dans en tout cas dans des annonces
politiques il y avait une crainte de
bousculer un peu les Français il y avait
une crainte de tout ça moi j'avais un
plan de sobriété qui était tout près
mais j'ai pas pu sortir à l'époque parce
que il y avait une augmentation des prix
d'énergie très forte qui était en train
de monter que on avait du coup des
priorités à gérer parce que tout ce que
je vous dis là ça se passe dans un
contexte ça se passe dans un contexte où
on a les prix de l'énergie qui qui
explosent où on a la présidence
française de l'Union européenne donc qui
fait que on est très occupé à cette
préparation là et il y a des dimensions
énergétiques dedans notamment sur les
marchés de l'énergie on a la guerre en
Ukraine qui arrive en février 2022 et
donc on doit gérer toutes ces crises là
mais qui ont au moins un mérite
c'est de mettre en lumière de manière
crue à quel point on est dépendant de
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur pour notre
approvisionnement en énergie et je crois
que cette crise a eu un mérite vraiment
c'est
d'accélérer cette prise de conscience et
donc de permettre d'aller plus vite dans
la mise en oeuvre d'un certain nombre de
mesures qui étaient nécessaires mais qui
était pas toujours facilement acceptable
et notamment un plan de sobriété qui
était absolument indispensable et qu'on
a dû accélérer pour pouvoir faire face
aux problèmes de manque de gaz notamment
et de manque de pétrole suite à la gare
vis-à-vis de la Russie voilà un petit
peu où on en est donc en conclusion moi
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que avant
j'avais vraiment de sentiment que sur la
politique énergétique il manquait un
pilote dans l'avion et que maintenant on
a un pilote ou en tout cas on a une
politique donc on est sur des bons rails
est-ce qu'on est au bout du chemin loin
de là est-ce qu'il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à faire évidemment
mais en tout cas
enfin on a une vraie politique
énergétique dans notre pays
merci beaucoup
qui devraient rassurer toute notre
commission d'enquête
j'aurai une première question
[Musique]
avant d'entrer dans la question
électrique qui a beaucoup occupé votre
propos liminaire
finalement quelle est la place de la
question des énergies fossiles en
matière de préoccupation notamment sur
le volet sécurité d'approvisionnement
vulnérabilité au ministère de l'Énergie
quand vous y êtes
quand j'y arrive
on est dans la situation qui est une
situation de toute façon qui va mettre
du temps à bouger c'est que malgré tout
le on est encore dépendant à peu près
pour la moitié même plus que la moitié
de notre de notre de notre production
d'énergie
consommée de l'énergie consommée à
45% puisque on a 55% de l'énergie
consommée sur notre territoire qui
produite en France sachant que quand on
parle de ça quand on dit 45 45% de
l'énergie
on a besoin de 45 pardon 55% d'énergie
consommée en France a été produite en
France et 45% est importé en sachant que
quand on parle de l'importation c'est
essentiellement des énergies fossiles le
reste effectivement on en produit on
produit du nucléaire on produit du de
des
renouvelables qu'elle soit thermique ou
qu'elle soit électrique et donc on a ce
problème là dès le départ on a le
problème que les énergies fossiles sont
des énergies extrêmement polluantes et
extrêmement émettrice de gaz à effet de
serre on sait quand j'arrive à mon à mon
ministère que si on veut tenir nos
objectifs de transition
écologique on doit baisser nos énergies
fossiles notre notre production on a
très peu de production mais notre
consommation d'énergie fossile donc moi
je dois appliquer ce qui a déjà été voté
dans la loi énergie climat la loi
énergie climat c'était la fermeture des
centrales à charbon
et on s'emploie à continuer ce travail
moi je suis sur la queue de comète on va
dire puisque il y avait déjà beaucoup de
choses qui avaient été engagées avant
moi quand j'arrive
celle du Havre est en train de fermer ou
enfin on est vraiment j'ai plus les on
est vraiment nier on a Saint-Avold qui
doit suivre et puis on a le sujet de
Cordemais avec avec
on n'a pas que Cordemais on a aussi
Gardanne donc on a ces quatre centrales
là et quand je termine on a réussi à
fermer celle qui devait être fermée et
on a le problème de Saint-Avold qu'on a
remis en
veille pour pouvoir passer l'hiver suite
aux problèmes que nous avions sur
l'approvisionnement en électricité à
cause des fermetures de réacteurs de
centrales nucléaires
donc moi mon sujet à ce moment-là sur
les fossiles c'est sur la production
c'est la fermeture des centrales à
charbon
donc à gérer aussi d'un point de vue
social puisque notamment agardane et
accords de mai on a on a des vrais
sujets à Gardanne de de
gestion
sociale de la transition et accordemer
avec avec des salariés qui sont très
intéressants parce qu'ils portent un
projet un projet pour redonner une
nouvelle fonction à la centrale de
Cordemais que moi je trouvais très
intéressant qui avait pas réussi à
aboutir et qu'on a réussi à relancer je
suis assez fier d'ailleurs qu'on ait
réussi à relancer ce projet sur corps de
mai notamment de c'était un projet de
Black Pelé
sur les autres énergies production
d'énergie on a une centrale à gaz qui
devait qui devait être lancé qui était
la dernière centrale qui avait été
lancée bien avant que j'arrive en
Bretagne
mais pour le reste le but et moi c'est
plutôt ceux à quoi je me suis attelé
c'est d'essayer de réduire notre
consommation d'énergie fossiles parce
que si on veut baisser nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre il y a pas le choix
et donc pour baisser notre consommation
d'énergie fossile il y avait deux moyens
de le faire il y avait la sobriété donc
c'est à dire réduire au maximum notre
consommation baisser la consommation
pour baisser la consommation vous pouvez
le faire de plusieurs manières soit en
revoyant un certain nombre de modes de
vie quand on prend plus le vélo c'est de
la sobriété on utilise moins sa voiture
donc voilà c'est
travailler à l'efficacité énergétique
donc vous avez des mesures que nous
avons prises notamment dans la loi
climat résilience pour accélérer
améliorer rendre plus facile la
rénovation des bâtiments les bâtiments
c'est 33% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est un secteur énorme et donc
il fallait absolument aller plus vite
sur la rénovation énergétique que ce
soit des bâtiments d'habitation des
bâtiments dans le tertiaire des
bâtiments publics d'une manière générale
donc on a pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour cela il y avait aussi donc
je vous l'ai dit des changements d'usage
donc soit
[Musique]
lâcher pour travailler au développement
d'une filière d'énergie de de voitures
électriques donc que ce soit de la
construction de voitures mais aussi de
développer une filière de batterie de
développer aussi tout un travail de
formation pour sur les les
lieux les sur les territoires concernés
de faire attention aussi à la transition
parce que la transition entre une
industrie de voiture électrique
thermique à électrique c'est quelque
chose qui se fait pas d'un claquement de
doigts de l'autre côté
il fallait aussi aider nos concitoyens à
pouvoir accéder à des voitures
électriques parce que les voitures
électriques sont plus chères tout
simplement et que
il y a un certain nombre de concitoyens
qui ont pas les moyens de se payer des
voitures électriques donc on a beaucoup
travaillé à la mise en place de mesures
d'aide pour que ce soit un crédit
d'impôt que ce soit une prime à la casse
que ce soit un certain nombre d'aides
pour pouvoir aider nos concitoyens à
pouvoir changer de voiture donc tout ça
ce sont des mécanismes qui prennent du
temps on le fait on l'a fait pour les
pour nos concitoyens je peux donner un
autre exemple pour l'industrie la
décarbonation de l'industrie est aussi
un moyen très important de baisser nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
donc l'utilisation d'énergie fossile on
a travaillé à travers le plan France
relance pour pour développer des des
aides pour la décarbonation de
l'industrie je pense par exemple
au fourneau à Dunkerque qui sont un
exemple emblématique mais qui représente
beaucoup et puis j'ai oublié de vous
dire aussi qu'on travaillait au
développement de nouvelles filières la
filière hydrogène par exemple sur
laquelle on a mis beaucoup
d'investissements mais qui est une des
nombreuses filières de la transition
je suis désolé mais en fait c'est
tellement vaste que vos questions on a
fait beaucoup d'auditions et je crois
qu'on a à chaque fois permis d'aller au
fond des choses je reviens juste sur la
question pour bien m'intéresser à
vous avez raison
sur les vulnérabilités sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement tout à fait vous
avez raison et je me suis éloignée de
votre question pardonnez-moi monsieur le
Président on a un problème de
souveraineté énergétique de la France
depuis toujours puisque
nous n'avons pas pu produire d'énergie
100% française
très depuis très très longtemps nous
avons besoin pour
toute à part sur le charbon je réfléchis
en même temps que je vous parle parce
qu'on avait du charbon on a eu du gaz
à lac mais maintenant malheureusement
nous n'avons plus
sur les énergies fossiles on en a encore
un petit peu mais en gros on est obligé
de les importer pour la production
d'électricité on est souverain dans
aucun domaine puisque sur les énergies
renouvelables on a besoin pour fabriquer
les différents composants des énergies
renouvelables de matériaux qu'on ne
trouve pas forcément en France pour le
nucléaire on a aussi besoin notamment
pour s'approvisionner en uranium de sa
provisionner à l'extérieur de la France
donc on n'a pas en fait on n'a pas
à ma connaissance sauf de manière
marginale de production
100% française d'énergie
donc en termes de souveraineté on a à
part je vous dis quand on se chauffer au
charbon c'est une fille qui vient des
mines qui vous dit ça quand on se fait
au charbon ou au gaz il y a très
longtemps
à cette époque-là on pouvait dire qu'on
était totalement souverain mais depuis
non
donc pour répondre à ça nous avons
travaillé surtout suite aux différentes
crises qui ont traversé
ce quinquennat et notamment la crise de
la covid qui a mis en lumière justement
ce besoin de se réapproprier une forme
de souveraineté on a missionné fille
Varin qui nous a fait un rapport très
intéressant pour essayer justement de
structurer un petit peu notre
approvisionnement de le diversifier
puisque vous savez que sur des sur des
matériaux extrêmement importants
notamment par exemple le lithium qui a
été
un des focus du rapport Varin
on est extrêmement dépendant de l'Asie
donc on a besoin d'abord un de
diversifier sa provisionnements donc il
va il y a un observatoire qui est prévu
dans ce rapport
des appels d'offres aussi qui ont été
lancés suite à ce rapport pour essayer
de diversifier les approvisionnements et
puis pour essayer aussi de
s'approvisionner chez nous
bien merci beaucoup j'en viens à ces
affaires de scénario
[Musique]
il faut juste que je comprenne bien une
articulation donc vous nous dites quand
vous arrivez au ministère votre
prédécesseur
excusez-moi j'arrive jamais à mettre ce
mot au féminin
votre prédécesseur a commandé ou en tout
cas élaborer avec RTE je sais pas on lui
demandera dans quel sens c'est construit
la proposition ou la commande
le ou en tout cas on est dans l'attente
on sait que les travaux sont menés du C2
France énergétique France énergie 2005
donc ça c'est dans les dans les tuyaux
et vous en avez connaissance
est-ce que vous savez
quels sont les hypothèses sur lesquelles
ce travail prospectif de RTE prospère
alors
de mémoire la première ministre qui
était ministre de l'énergie à l'époque
enfin de la transition écologique avait
fait une commande donc c'était un
courrier à RTE de commande de d'un
rapport présentant des scénarios qui sur
lesquels on pourrait on pourrait
s'appuyer rTE est assez
usuel habitué à faire des scénarios ils
en faisaient assez régulièrement
je me souviens qu'on s'appuyait beaucoup
nous sur le scénario en pair par exemple
qui était sorti en 2017 qui était un
scénario très intéressant que je vous
invite à lire si vous avez l'occasion
mais
là il avait été demandé à
RTE de faire ces scénarios à la lumière
des nouvelles
[Musique]
orientations que nous avions prises
notamment sur le fait de d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 qui était une
nouvelle orientation puisqu'elle venait
de la loi énergique climat et pour
essayer aussi de tenir compte de de
toutes les nouvelles connaissances que
nous avions et c'est en ça que c'était
très intéressant et donc moi quand je
suis arrivé
j'ai évidemment rencontré les
responsables de RTE à plusieurs reprises
parce que je vous rappelle qu'ils sont
aussi en charge des des réseaux
d'électricité et donc s'ils font partie
des interlocuteurs comme ministre de
l'Énergie rencontre régulièrement pour
faire un petit peu l'état des lieux de
où on en est sur sur tel ou tel projet
et
donc je savais que leur rapport était en
cours mais j'avais des informations sur
les points d'étape mais j'avais je n'ai
pas eu le rapport en tout cas dans une
version
consolidée avant très mais c'est normal
ils ont pris le temps de faire de
travail et c'est un travail d'ailleurs
qui à ma connaissance est vraiment
reconnu comme un travail sérieux par
tout le monde par tous les acteurs quels
qu'ils sont donc j'en viens à ma
question un peu plus précise
c'est-à-dire que donc ce scénario France
énergétique 2050 il est commandé par
Madame borne qui vous précède quand vous
arrivez au ministère vous avez
connaissance de la commande et de de
dire de la palette d'études enfin ou de
scénario étudié même si vous êtes
peut-être pas le détail
et vous commandez à ce moment-là je sais
plus que quand j'arrive je découvre un
peu mais enfin en tout cas entre le
moment globalement dans les semaines qui
arrivent enfin vous avez connaissance
peut-être pas au moment de la
transmission
oui dans les semaines moi je sais plus
mais et donc vous vous commandez un
scénario 100% millénaire
alors quand je vous en ai parlé je me
suis dit que j'aurais dû vérifier quand
est-ce que cette commande avait été
faite
je pourrais si vous voulez je vérifier
cela et vous transmettre l'information
par écrit parce que je ne sais plus si
c'était une demande qui avait été
également faite par Elisabeth borne
et c'est fort possible mais comme à
l'époque il était d'usage qu'on qu'on
travaille beaucoup ensemble puisque moi
j'étais président de la commission
développement durable sur ces sujets là
je ne voudrais pas lui voler la
maternité de de cette commande mais en
tout cas ce scénario lui arrive avant
c'est pas que RTE parce que c'était
important aussi que l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie qui est une
agence qui n'est pas réputée pour être
farouchement anti-nucléaire et qui avait
l'intérêt d'être une agence
internationale et donc d'avoir un point
de vue un peu distancier par rapport à
nous qui sommes dans nos bagarres
franco-française mais qui avait vraiment
un point de vue distancié de pouvoir
dire les choses et donc c'est en ça que
ce rapport était intéressant
c'est ce qui est surprenant c'est qu'il
soit concomitant sans l'être vraiment à
des niveaux d'expertise différents et
parfois contradictoire dans leur
conclusion
à ma connaissance ils sont pas
contradictoires le rapport de RTE future
énergétique 200050 creuse un peu le
sujet en fait le rapport aie n'était pas
là pour creuser le sujet et toutes les
conditions il était là pour examiner si
oui ou non il était possible d'avoir un
un mix sans électrique 100% renouvelable
en 2050 ils arrivent à la conclusion
qu'il est possible de le faire
mais en expliquant que pour le faire il
y a énormément de conditions à remplir
qui ne sont pas simples notamment sur la
question des réseaux de l'adaptation des
réseaux mais bon de toute façon
adaptation des réseaux faudra la faire
quoi qu'il advienne
sur la question du stockage sur la
question d'un certain nombre
d'innovations énergétique et sur la
question des financements donc on avait
donc c'était pas du tout un rapport je
veux surtout pas
transformer ce qu'ils ont dit dans ce
rapport c'était pas du tout un rapport
qui disait on y va c'est c'est la
meilleure solution il ne se prononce pas
dans ce rapport sur est-ce que il faut
le faire ou pas c'est un rapport
purement technique
techniquement est-ce que c'est possible
ou pas
bon du coup quand le futur énergétique
2050 est rendu par RTE vous nous dites
voilà là on commence à y voir clair et
c'est là qu'on commence à construire des
choix
c'est un peu surprenant
par rapport à des auditions qu'on a pu
mener je pense notamment à celle de
Monsieur ribado Dumas qui était le
directeur de cabinet d'Edouard Philippe
donc juste avant vous finalement vous
êtes à ce moment-là à l'Assemblée parce
que vous n'êtes pas au gouvernement qui
nous explique que finalement eux dès
qu'ils arrivent en 2017
voilà il y a beaucoup de bullshits ils
font le ménage il y a pas de souci ils
savent ce qu'il faut faire et ils
préparent la majorité à ce qu'il faudra
faire parce que globalement la majorité
comprend pas tout ce sujet là et qui
sont là pour leur expliquer
enfin moi c'est comme ça que j'ai
compris cette audition monsieur le
rapporteur je vous vois un peu ticket
bon donc je suis surpris de vous
entendre dire que c'est à partir du
rapport RTE que tout change alors qu'on
a le directeur de cabinet du premier
ministre qui nous explique que pendant
les trois ans pendant lesquelles ils
étaient aux affaires bon ils ont préparé
tout ça quoi
alors mais Maxime à culpa je n'ai pas vu
l'audition de Monsieur Riba de Dima et
je vais m'empresser de la regarder pour
pour écouter
attentivement ce qui ce qui est ce qu'il
a dit moi je ne peux pas vous dire ce
qui s'est passé au gouvernement quand je
n'y étais pas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que il y avait suite à la suite
encore une fois à
l'accord de Paris suite à la loi énergie
climat il y avait
des volontés exprimées et une certaine
forme de dynamique engagée mais il n'y
avait pas de définition claire de ce
qu'on allait faire on se rendait compte
qu'on était en train de dériver sur les
énergies renouvelables on se rendait
compte que sur le nucléaire on
n'arrivait pas à avoir un discours qui
était un discours
[Musique]
suffisamment clair
dans un sens ou dans l'autre enfin j'ai
envie de vous dire dans un sens ou dans
l'autre mais à un moment il fallait se
décider sur ce qu'on faisait et les
je vous dis le fond de ma pensée il
avait été décidé que on allait descendre
la part du nucléaire à 50% en 2025 puis
déjà encore une fois pourquoi on décale
en 2035 parce qu'on a été un fichu
collectivement de tenir nos objectifs
en dehors de ça et de la fermeture de
Fessenheim qui je le reconnaît
totalement a été
a été menée à son terme je sais votre
opinion monsieur le Président sur le
sujet mais peu importe un moment j'ai
envie de dire quand on prend une
décision le pire quand on fait quand on
est responsable politique et quand on
met en place des politiques c'est de
prendre des décisions et de pas les
suivre des faits ça perturbe tout le
monde personne ne sait à quoi s'en tenir
on sait pas où on va ça inquiète tout le
monde à un moment il faut essayer et
c'est ce qui fait que après quand on
vote d'autres lois et là je m'en suis
rendu compte avec la loi climat
résilience les gens sont persuadés que
ce qui est voté toute façon ce sera pas
appliqué donc il ne se prépare pas et
donc quand ça arrive bah il semble tout
bizarre donc on a maintenant un besoin
de restaurer la crédibilité politique
dans notre pays la crédibilité de la
décision politique et pour moi rétablir
la crédibilité de la décision politique
c'est quand on prend une décision
démocratiquement tous ces trucs là ont
été votés quand on prend une décision et
bien on s'y tient et donc sur cette
question de
de la politique énergétique qui était
menée jusqu'à jusqu'au discours de
Belfort oui il y a des choses qui sont
qui sont lancées je vous ai parlé de la
loi climat énergie je vous ai parlé de
l'objectif à 2050 mais ce que ce que je
constate c'est que on n'arrive pas à
développer les renouvelables que sur le
nucléaire personne sait où on en est
donc on a d'un côté et je pense que
comme il avait été décidé que on allait
baisser la part du nucléaire et que une
bonne partie
de la classe politique de ce pays
n'était absolument pas prête à le faire
absolument pas prête à le faire pourquoi
parce qu'il n'avait pas du tout
conscience de pourquoi il fallait le
faire et ben ça traîner et donc résultat
je vous rappelle que normalement d'ici
2035 on devrait fermer 14 réacteurs
c'est évident que on y arrivera pas on y
arrivera pas parce que on sait pas
donner les moyens de le faire la
consommation électrique constante
ce que nous a expliqué c'est ce que nous
a expliqué les pères de la loi de Mika
oui parce que c'était
parce que c'était un pourcentage c'est
50%. donc mais juste un dernier point
là-dessus ça a pas ça a pas été fait
cette histoire cette histoire de la
baisse de la baisse et de la fermeture
d'un certain nombre de réacteurs ça a
été fait pour deux raisons il y a une
raison politique justement ceux qui ont
fait la loi de 2015 nous expliquer
justement que c'était une baisse de la
part relative et pas forcément des
fermetures c'est là que peut-être que
vous avez voté la loi de 2015
bien sûr que je l'ai voté mais pas
forcément de fermeture je pense que on
est tous entre gens raisonnable ici on
sait que tous les réacteurs nucléaires
du parc nucléaire vont fermer
tous la question c'est de savoir quand
et la question c'est de savoir est-ce
que on attend pour faire pour parler de
manière très crue est-ce qu'on attend
qu'il tombe en panne
pour les fermer ou est-ce que on essaye
d'anticiper pour éviter de se retrouver
face à des graves crises
d'approvisionnement de notre pays en
électricité c'est ça la question quand
on a décidé de faire une trajectoire de
la baisse de la part du nucléaire la
première raison c'était une raison de
diversifier le mix électrique et je
pense que maintenant tout le monde a
compris à quel point il était dangereux
d'un point de vue de l'approvisionnement
d'électricité d'être dépendant d'une
seule source d'énergie quelle qu'elle
soit et donc il faut diversifier son mix
pour pouvoir justement compter sur une
autre source d'énergie quand une vient à
manquer et là je crois ce qu'on a vécu
l'hiver dernier est assez révélateur de
ce point de vue là donc ça c'est la
première raison et la deuxième raison
c'est parce que on ne repas quand on a
construit un parc de réacteurs en 10 ans
je vous rappelle on se les dit tout à
l'heure entre 79 et 92 on a
construits réacteurs en tout cas on a
raccordé 53 réacteurs
vous m'excuserez si je me trompe à une
ou deux unités près hein mais non mais
parce que je connais je connais mes amis
je connais un certain nombre de mes amis
qui vont dire que tout ce que j'ai dit
c'est n'importe quoi parce que je me
suis trompé de un ou deux de nombre de
réacteurs peu importe en ordre
non justement mais en l'occurrence vous
avez en disant construit une
cinquantaine de réacteurs donc de
manière tout à fait logique
j'ai dit nous c'est nous sommes la
France
ah j'ai dit vous autant pour moi
peu importe écoutez écoutez le fond de
ce que je dis monsieur le Président
parce que c'est parce que c'est très
important c'est très important
on a construit tous ces réacteurs en
disant
on sait donc que ils peuvent atteindre
la date limite de consommation
à peu près tout en même temps
est-ce que c'est responsable de se dire
que on va laisser cette date limite
arriver
en tirant tirantir en tirant pour les
utiliser le plus possible et ne pas se
mettre ne pas prendre les précautions
d'usage qui sont des précautions de se
dire si en total théorie on les garde
tous ensemble en fonctionnement jusqu'à
la fin de leur vie ça veut dire qu'on va
devoir arrêter en disant 50 réacteurs
50 réacteurs
est-ce que alors tout ça a été théorisé
par tous les gens qui s'intéressent au
sujet ça s'appelle l'effet falaise
est-ce que c'est raisonnable de se dire
que à la fin de leur vie en disant on va
arrêter 50 réacteurs moi je pense que ça
ne l'est pas ça n'est absolument pas
raisonnable et donc que et en plus en
faisant ça on ne se prémunit pas contre
le risque d'une anomalie générique de
on a pu voir d'ailleurs que ça existait
on ne se on ne se prémunit contre aucun
risque et donc il était important qu'on
puisse se dire on va avoir une
trajectoire douce de fermeture de
réacteurs pour préparer les territoires
puis en plus comme là en plus ils vont
être remplacés par d'autres réacteurs
donc bon mais ils vont pour préparer les
territoires parce qu'on va pas remplacer
partout pour faire en sorte que si
jamais on a un problème sur un certain
nombre de réacteurs comme on aura prévu
dans la montée en charge en ciseaux des
énergies renouvelables on n'aura pas de
problème d'approvisionnement en
électricité
et et ensuite et bien si jamais on a le
moindre problème on sera protégé c'était
ça la ppect c'était une planification de
simplement de de précaution
d'anticipation de responsabilité et il
est dommage que comme on a pas voulu
respecter pas voulu je pense respecter
cette PPE ce soir retrouver dans un
corner qui fait que on a dû tout
modifier et revoir un certain nombre
d'objectifs qu'on avait donc n'a pas
voulu respecter la PPE donc entre qu'on
soit d'accord sur les dates donc entre
2015 et
2020 finalement puisque
c'est la date où on corrige cette
trajectoire de la PPE
on va vraiment corriger on va on a
corrigé dans la loi énergie climat mais
maintenant la vraie correction la vraie
PPE
[Musique]
qui à mon avis va avoir une importance
très forte c'est celle qui va être votée
par par nous-même cette année du coup
j'en viens justement à ce qu'on nous
dites c'est le ce point de bascule de la
reprise en main ou même peut-être la
prise en main puisque
c'est comme ça que vous le présentiez de
la stratégie énergétique donc en février
22 oui c'est le symbole quoi
comment du coup le Ministère chargé au
fond de la mise de la définition et de
la mise en oeuvre de la politique
énergétique est associé à la préparation
de d'un discours comme celui-là qui est
finalement le discours de prospective de
prise en main tel que vous l'avez
présenté la stratégie énergétique de
notre pays bon de manière très classique
on a eu un certain nombre de réunions
que ce soit les réunions des services
qui ont évidemment préparé un certain
nombre de dossiers d'aspects techniques
on a eu des des réunions politiques donc
avec les autres ministres concernés avec
le Premier ministre avec le président de
la République pour discuter de tout cela
ce qui paraît être assez logique on a eu
des réunions où on a regardé ce rapport
et et les scénarios
rien de
manière normale en fait j'ai envie de
vous dire en fait j'ai un problème de
temporalité c'est je comprends pas très
bien comment
vous pouvez finalement en janvier 2022
avoir des propos
assez acide
publique sur notre capacité à
construire des centrales nucléaires à
assurer la sécurité d'approvisionnement
avec des centrales nucléaires et puis
finalement nous expliquer que c'est
justement la période pendant laquelle
vous prépariez le discours en tout cas
la planification stratégique qui est
présentée en février où on dit on va on
va lancer 6 puis 8 EPR qui seront dans
les EPR 2 j'ai bien compris dont les
premiers seront en service au plus tard
en 2035 donc voilà j'ai pour moi une
contradiction
je m'en souviens plus des propos précis
que j'ai tenus à ce moment là je me
souviens que à cette période là j'avais
des paroles un peu acide pour reprendre
votre terme
vis-à-vis d'EDF qui m'expliquait que ils
avaient
un certain nombre un nombre certain de
réacteurs à l'arrêt pour des raisons qui
pour certaines étaient des raisons tout
à fait valables puisque il y a eu un
problème
d'arrêt dès maintenant cependant la
crise mais c'est des arrêts qui ont duré
deux mois donc
qui ont duré deux mois mais qui ont du
coup
bouleversé tout le calendrier de
maintenant des réacteurs et la
maintenance des réacteurs c'est pas
optionnel c'est nécessaire pour la
sûreté mais j'étais un peu acide parce
que c'était deux mois en au printemps
2020 là on est en fin 2021
parce que les propos assis je me
souviens de fin de 2021 mais c'était
peut-être début 2022 enfin 2021 je
convoque le président de EDF dans mon
bureau pour lui demander où il en est
sur cette sur ces maintenances de
réacteur et sur les réacteurs fermés
entre temps on a découvert les corrosion
sous contrainte sur les réacteurs
nucléaires qui font que on a pas de
perspective sur la réouverture d'un
certain nombre de réacteurs dont on
avait besoin pour satisfaire à la au
besoin d'électricité de nos concitoyens
dans un dans une période d'hiver et donc
à ce moment là moi j'ai des prévisions y
compris de RTE qui disent ben si
on a pas suffisamment de réacteurs
rallumés et si cet hiver il fait froid
on peut avoir des problèmes et on peut
devoir gérer des coupures d'électricité
dans notre pays et donc oui je suis un
petit peu fâché contre DF et je suis à
ce moment-là d'ailleurs je demande au
PDG EDF 1 d'organiser un audit pour qui
nous explique comment ça se fait que sur
des maintenances de réacteurs ils
n'arrivent pas à mieux s'organiser que
cela donc oui je suis un tout petit peu
énervée mais ça n'a pas ça n'a pas avoir
mais peut-être que
c'était pas par rapport à EDF c'était
par rapport à notre capacité à
construire des centrales nucléaires que
vous mettez en doute en janvier 2021
pour finalement accompagner 2021 2022
pardon on me dit 11 janvier 2022 je suis
un peu dyslexique 11 janvier 2022 pour
des un discours de février 2022 donc un
mois après qui annonce finalement un
chantier prospectif autour de 14
réacteurs quand je
pas 14 ans je vous rappelle que c'est du
chantier prospectif tout à fait tout à
fait mais donc il y a pas d'annonce de
14 de 14 réacteurs si c'est une option 8
voilà j'ai écouté
si c'est une option de 8 le
moi je dois gérer à ce moment-là donc
une crise énergétique lourde un problème
d'approvisionnement dans notre pays où
je me retrouve à devoir prévoir en cas
grave de couper l'électricité à mes
concitoyens donc je suis fâché contre
Dave non je me dis comment EDF qui
n'arrive pas à faire de la simple
maintenance de réacteur
comment EDF qui vient de me redonner
parce que je sais plus quand on a eu les
derniers
les derniers épisodes des reports de
l'ouverture du de Flamanville de
Flamanville 3 donc le Pr de Flamanville
je suis un petit peu fâché parce que je
me dis si on a des problèmes comme ça
sur l'existant et sur le réacteur
pilote de flamants ville on n'arrive pas
à délivrer comme on dit en franglais
c'est c'est effectivement compliqué
au-delà de ça il y a eu des réponses qui
ont été apportées des réponses sur
d'abord la formation on a un vrai besoin
de formation sur les filières nucléaires
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
chers collègues que dans la mission dans
la commission d'enquête sur la sûreté
nucléaire nous avions déjà à l'époque
préconisée
qu'il y ait de meilleure formation pour
sur dans les domaines du nucléaire
il y a eu aussi un gros travail qui a
été fait pour essayer de
redesigner le Pr et donc de proposer à
la construction des EPR 2
donc qui tiendrait compte de du retour
d'expérience des difficultés du chantier
de le père 1 donc qui sont supposés
apporter des réponses à un certain
nombre de problèmes qui ont été soulevés
lors de la sur le chantier de
Flamanville mais aussi d'ailleurs sur
les autres chantiers que ce soit sur
auto ou sur Ty Chan
voilà donc j'ai j'ai à partir de ce
moment là et à partir du moment où il y
a aussi beaucoup d'investissements qui
ont été mis dans le plan de relance sur
la recherche sur le nucléaire et sur les
compétences je considère que le
président après fait ses choix
alors
justement sur les six premiers EP2 à
construire
est-ce que
la mobilisation de la filière
industrielle notamment la préparation de
la chaudière de la cuve elle attend
février 2022 où est-ce que des
précommandes
type préparer six cuves ou trois cuves
ou deux cuves sont lancés avant
il y avait des des travaux qui étaient
commencés avant parce que il fallait
faire un certain nombre de tests
qui
de tests qui étaient des tests de
résistance d'un certain nombre de
matériaux dont on m'avait expliqué et
est-ce pour me faire plaisir que ces
tests étaient nécessaires de toute façon
même si il n'y avait pas de de commande
de nouveaux EPA il y avait aussi eu des
volontés qui avaient été affichées par
EDF de
préenter pas présenté pardon du terme
mais de
pré-remper un certain nombre de terrain
pour
installer les futurs EPR 2 et à l'époque
j'avais mais j'étais pas la seule on
avait dit EDF que ça fait peut-être pas
mettre la charrue avant les bœufs
avant le discours de Belfort là vous
faites appel à ma mémoire mais je
pourrais je pourrais vous donner des
éléments que
je pense qu'ils sont publics donc il y a
pas de problème
mais c'était c'était sur sur des
histoires de résistance de matériaux
j'ai à peu près je suis à peu près sûr
de ça des matériaux qui qui composent
notamment les cuves
du coup se déroule le discours de
Belfort et vous nous dites dans votre
propos introductif qu'ensuite tout est
mis en ordre de marche
en trois mois tout est réglé bah non
bien sûr que non je dis je dis que ce
discours il pose les bases sur
lesquelles on peut s'appuyer et donc à
partir de ce moment là quand on est sur
des rails c'est pas pour ça qu'on est
arrivé à la destination monsieur le
Président mais par contre on est dans
une direction c'est à dire que là
derrière on peut enclencher un certain
nombre de choses notamment sur la
question de lever les obstacles au
développement des énergies renouvelables
lancé différents appels d'offres et
avoir un objectif clair c'est à dire que
maintenant on a des chiffres on sait
combien on doit faire d'éoliennes en mer
on sait combien on doit faire des
éoliennes terrestres on sait combien on
doit faire tout voltaïque on sait et
donc à partir du moment où on a des
objectifs clairs c'est beaucoup plus
simple c'est beaucoup plus simple et on
a identifié parce que ça ça avait été
fait déjà depuis un certain temps les
obstacles qui restent à lever que ce
soit sur la participation du public que
ce soit des obstacles législatif une
a été voté récemment pour cela
il y avait manifestement je l'avais pas
identifié pour être très franche au
moment où j'étais ministre des obstacles
d'ordre législatif sur le nucléaire
donc il y a une loi qui arrive et
évidemment je prendrai ma part dans
l'étude de cette loi
donc un discours seul
permet finalement de recaler les choses
de mobiliser une filière et de mettre
tout ça en ordre de marche ah mais j'en
suis persuadé monsieur le Président je
considère que ce qui nous avait manqué
avant c'était clairement une vision
c'était clairement une direction
politique je
ça me fait penser mais comparaison n'est
absolument pas raison donc s'il vous
plaît ne considérez pas que je compare
le discours de Belfort à quoi que ce
soit d'autre mais ça me fait penser
parce qu'il s'avère que j'ai un prisme
d'aéronautique et un prisme aussi sur
sur
mes rêves de jeunesse d'être astronaute
mais moi je me souviens que ce
et oui mais ça n'empêche pas d'avoir un
cerveau et de s'en servir
contrairement à ce que certains prennent
nucléaires disent j'ai quand j'ai
l'homme à marcher sur la lune parce que
il y a eu un discours prononcé par le
président Kennedy
le discours qui était prononcé par le
président Kennedy dans un grand stade je
ne sais plus dans quelle ville est un
discours absolument fondateur et dont on
pourrait d'ailleurs reprendre un certain
nombre de choses enfin moi je recommande
à tous les responsables politiques c'est
un discours qui a donné une vision qui a
donné une direction et qui a permis de
mettre en ordre de marche tout le monde
alors loin de moi l'idée de comparer le
discours de Belfort au discours de
Kennedy mais simplement c'est pour vous
donner une illustration c'est pour vous
donner non non je la comparaison
vraiment s'arrête là mais c'est pour se
donner donner une illustration que on ne
peut pas faire avancer un pays faire
avancer des gens faire avancer des
filières si on ne sait pas où on va et
si on ne si on n'a pas une idée claire
de ce qu'on veut faire le discours de
Belfort à se mérite là
il enlève pas il y a encore plein de
détails dans lesquels il faut rentrer de
manière plus précise et il faut que ce
discours il y a un petit point quand
même qui est important il faut que ce
discours il soit validé démocratiquement
c'est pour ça que la PPE est importante
parce que la PPE elle valide
l'orientation politique et donner par le
Président de la République en 2022 même
si on peut considérer que le fait qu'il
ait été élu sur ce programme là donne
aussi la légitimité au gouvernement de
continuer dans cette direction là
mais ce qui signifie aussi que des
discours
désorganisés peuvent
sans acte concrets désorganiser une
filière
je ne vous suis pas poursuivez que je
comprenne ce que vous voulez dire parce
que les discours des organisés peuvent
désorganiser une filière
un discours organisé suffit à organiser
la filière des discours des organisés
suffirait donc à désorganiser la filière
je pense que je ne vois pas trop à quoi
vous faites référence mais je peux vous
dire que quand on ne sait pas où on va
on y arrive pas en général
on n'arrive pas à aller dans la bonne
direction on a besoin d'avoir une
direction c'est pas suffisant en soi
évidemment mais c'est une base
fondamentale depuis quelques semaines
avec le rapporteur nous travaillons sur
une période de l'histoire de notre
politique énergétique où on a peut-être
le sentiment qu'on ne savait pas où on
allait ah mais je partage cette
je partage cette idée je crois qu'il y a
eu un vrai problème de vision et un vrai
problème aussi de prise de
responsabilité politique
dernière question pour moi
peut-être
si en lien également avec l'exercice de
vos fonctions ministériels et puis de
l'ensemble de votre travaux en matière
énergétique vous aviez dans vos
délégations la Sûreté Nucléaire ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas d'avoir un
ministre chargé et de la question de la
production énergétique donc du nucléaire
et de la Sûreté Nucléaire ça a pu
fluctuer
vous avez évoqué une période pendant
laquelle vous avez demandé peut-être
plus de résultats à EDF et de clarté
dans la disponibilité du parc
l'entretien du parc c'est une période
aussi qui a pu être animée par un
certain nombre de batailles en coulisses
sur la question de
[Musique]
du contrôle de la Sûreté Nucléaire
comment est-ce que vous vous projetez
dans l'évolution des institutions
indépendantes et de contrôle la sûreté
nucléaire en France écoutez moi j'ai
découvert comme tout le monde qu'il y
avait un projet de
on sait pas très bien d'ailleurs ce que
c'est que ce projet pour l'instant mais
qui
voudraient peut-être
faire fusionner ou en tout cas se
rapprocher très fort
l'IRSN et la SN
j'imagine que c'est ça que vous
mentionnez
j'ai exprimé d'ailleurs publiquement mon
incompréhension sur sur cela j'ai
toujours été une fervente défenseuse et
de la SN et de l'IRSN dont je trouve que
ces deux établissements font un travail
extraordinaire et de faire un travail
très nécessaire on a besoin de ce sont
ce sont des des
travaux de grande qualité qui sont
vendus par des uns et par les autres et
la SN a montré d'ailleurs que elle avait
une indépendance qui était tout à fait
utile pour pour donner confiance aussi
dans dans les politiques qui sont menées
et donc moi je suis très attentive au
fait qu'il puisse bien faire leur
travail que la SN est toujours demandé
à récupérer l'IRSN c'est un secret de
polichinelle
moi je trouvais je trouve toujours que
le fait qu'on sépare l'expertise et la
décision sur le modèle d'ailleurs de de
nos agences de sécurité sanitaire par
exemple
et quelque chose d'assez sain parce que
ça permet de ne pas donner l'impression
ce qui pourrait arriver s'ils étaient
dans le même établissement que une
décision puisse avoir été prise sur la
base d'expertise qui aurait pu être
commandée qui aurait pu être
télécommandé et je pense que c'est pas
un service à rendre à la SN surtout en
ce moment surtout là en ce moment où il
va y avoir des décisions qui vont être
prises assez lourdes sur des
constructions nouveaux réacteurs
et au moment où ils ont beaucoup de
travail sur sur les mesures postukushima
je ne comprends pas que la SN ne voit
pas que ça risque de décrédibiliser leur
travail parce que ça risque de semer le
doute et de semer la suspicion alors que
là le système tel qu'il est n'est
peut-être pas parfait il peut y avoir
des améliorations mais en tout cas le
système fonctionne bien
l'IRSN les travaux de l'URSS sont
excellents ils sont reconnus par tous
on peut nous faire appel à l'IRSN aussi
et d'ailleurs j'avais fait appel à
l'IRSN quand j'étais rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête sur le nucléaire
sur la sûreté nucléaire et il nous avait
fait des rapports excellents ils en ont
fait aussi dans le cadre de la CNDP sur
dans le cadre de leur débat je ne sais
plus lequel
sur cette équation sur sur le PR2 je
sais plus ou alors c'était sur les
déchets c'était sur les déchets je crois
c'était sur les déchets c'était sur les
déchets ouais c'est ça c'est pardon oui
c'était sur les déchets et donc ils font
un travail extraordinaire on peut faire
appel à eux
régulièrement ils font aussi des travaux
de recherche dont je me demande ce
qu'ils vont devenir s'il y a s'il y a
une fusion ou quelque chose qui
ressemble à une fusion voilà au-delà de
ça difficile d'en dire plus
parce que nous avons finalement très peu
d'informations mais en tout cas ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi
maintenant
lancer quelque chose de ce type alors
que le système fonctionne bien
et qui en tout cas il y avait pas
urgence à mon avis merci monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement pourrait faire l'hypothèse
que c'est parce qu'il y a une loi en
cours d'examen sur l'accélération des
installations nucléaire peut-être pour
commencer sur ce sujet là si vous le
permettez sur sur la sûreté reprendre
les derniers éléments que vous avez eu
c'est d'abord parler madame la ministre
et d'abord je vous remercie pour à la
fois votre disponibilité et les
premières réponses que vous avez porté
au nombreuses questions du Président
vous avez sur la question de la
potentiel réforme de la Sûreté Nucléaire
évoquait l'importance de l'indépendance
bien sûr de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire qu'est-ce qui à nouveau avec
toutes les réserves qui qui sont
impliquées par le les données existantes
ou connues de la potentielle réforme
vous ferez penser qu'une réforme
organisationnelle aurait un impact sur
l'indépendance de la SN pour le dire
autrement en l'état des informations
disponibles l'idée que l'institut qui
s'occupe de l'expertise et de
l'instruction des dossiers soit passe
d'un établissement public
d'un épique à
de l'ASN viendrait mettre en cause ou
diminuer la dimension indépendante ou de
l'Autorité de sûreté ou de l'Institut
d'expertise
alors d'abord
je n'avais pas échappé qu'il y avait une
loi sur l'accélération du nucléaire mais
je considérerai comme extrêmement mal
venu qu'une réforme qui est une réforme
lourde sur un sujet complexe le sujet de
la sûreté nucléaire c'est un sujet sur
lequel tout le monde s'accorde pour dire
que c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat
que une réforme comme celle là puisse
être parce que nous avons nous avons le
projet de loi c'est pas dedans donc
puisse arriver
par amendement sans étude d'impact
sur un sujet pareil je pense que ce
serait au minimum malvenu
voilà je c'est mon avis et je le partage
mais
je pense que ce serait ce serait plutôt
se tirer une balle dans le pied pour
ceux qui veulent faire avancer les
choses
encore une fois
on est sur un système qui a été lancé je
crois que c'était dans la loi Brotte
c'est c'est assez vieux tout ça
c'est un système qui permet d'avoir d'un
côté un organisme d'expertise qui est un
organisme qui est effectivement un
établissement public et de l'autre côté
une autorité indépendante on s'est rendu
compte que cette autorité indépendante
et je l'avais vu encore une fois pendant
ma commission d'enquête c'est une
autorité qui subit des pressions énormes
mais énormes quand une autorité de ce
type peut décider de la fermeture d'un
réacteur nucléaire
on est où peu décidé d'ailleurs de
l'arrêt de centrales nucléaire complète
on peut imaginer ce que ça veut dire en
terme de d'enjeux financiers que ça
représente en termes d'enjeux d'emploi
en termes d'enjeux de tout ce que vous
voulez donc on a besoin de préserver
justement l'autorité de cette de cette
autorité indépendante et donc de
préserver sa crédibilité elle a
construit cette crédibilité avec les
années et aujourd'hui cette crédibilité
elle est reconnue par tout le monde
le fait que l'expertise soit en dehors
même si tout le monde dit qu'il irasn et
le bras armé de la SN donc la SN est
quand même un donneur d'ordre pour
l'URSS qui est reconnu etc mais le fait
que l'IRS l'IRSN soit en dehors fait que
on a accès
beaucoup plus facilement il y a beaucoup
plus de dialogue entre les autres c'est
à dire la société civile ça veut dire
les différents acteurs et l'IRSN pour
pouvoir comprendre sur quelle base se
fonde une décision de la SN à partir du
moment où tout ça s'intègre au sein de
la SN comment vous pouvez avoir ces
vérifications là comment vous pouvez
être sûr que
à un moment
la SN parce que il y aura eu plein de
pression va dire bon est-ce que vous
pouvez bien vérifier que vous êtes sûr
que vous voyez ce que je veux dire on
peut pas il y aura pas la transparence
qui a aujourd'hui
obligatoirement il y aura pas la
transparence parce que on aura on aura
plus cette séparation qui est une
séparation qui permet
que l'IRSN ne rentre pas des comptes
qu'à la SN moi je trouve que
au mieux ça n'apporte pas grand chose et
au pire ça apporte de la suspicion et
encore une fois en France on a décidé
que sur des sur d'autres types de de
d'autorité
de surta sur d'autres sur d'autres
domaines comme notamment les autorités
sanitaires on sait toujours maintenant
en France l'expertise de la prise de
décision et je pense que ce système là a
fait ses preuves a montré que ça
marchait je ne comprends pas encore une
fois
c'est une incompréhension que j'exprime
je ne comprends pas
en quoi il était urgent de changer
quelque chose qui fonctionne bien qui
peut être amélioré il y a peut-être des
histoires de calendrier la SN a beaucoup
beaucoup de décisions à rendre il y a
notamment justement toutes les visites
ils vont avoir toutes les visites
décennales de toutes les centrales qui
arrivent à un certain âge et de tous les
réacteurs qui arrivent à un certain âge
que il y a aussi les mesures
postukushima il y a aussi des gros
enjeux là auxquels va faire face la SN
sur la construction de nouvelles
piscines entreposage sur les sur la
gestion des déchets etc donc ils sont
débordés qu'ils aient besoin de plus de
moyens peut-être et dans ces cas-là il
faut leur donner et pour l'IRSN de la
même manière mais
en le faisant de cette manière là je
pense que en terme de signal politique
on se trompe
et que si on veut relancer
comme ça a été annoncé des des
futurs réacteurs nucléaires je ne vois
pas pourquoi on vient brouiller le
message sur la sûreté
je vous remercie j'ai bien compris le
votre pignon sur la partie
signal politique mais je suis pas sûr
d'avoir compris ce que ce que vous
voulez dire enfin sur l'impact correct
une réorganisation ou une
restructuration de la manière dont est
répartie aujourd'hui l'expertise d'une
part d'autre part la prise de décision
c'est à dire que j'ai cru comprendre que
vous évoquiez par exemple la publicité
la transparence le débat la recherche la
recherche d'un organisme de recherche de
comprendre en quoi
un changement organisationnel si un
certain nombre de critères que vous avez
évoqué de manière ou sous-jacente ou
explicite était maintenu ou satisfait
une telle réorganisation serait par
essence problématique
encore une fois par essence
et c'est aussi des normes l'i1 dit que
il y a un vrai besoin de d'avoir une
séparation
et en tout cas une indépendance des
organismes de réglementation donc ça ça
on n'a pas de sujet le fait que
des organismes comme l'IRSN
ont besoin de pouvoir s'acquitter de
leur mission sans être en fait obligé de
répondre sans arrêt aux commandes de la
SN ça veut dire que sur
j'essaye de vous trouver un exemple qui
pourrait être
l'ASN a un programme
l'IRSN évidemment doit répondre aux
commandes de la SN mais le fait que
l'IRSN a une indépendance peut lui
permettre de dire
écoutez moi j'ai besoin de creuser un
peu plus telle ou tel sujet parce que il
s'avère que ce sont des sujets dont nous
pouvons avoir besoin si ils sont dans le
calendrier de l'ASN ils auront plus le
temps de creuser les autres sujets moi
je vous donne un exemple
nous avons quand j'ai fait ma
quand j'ai été rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête sur la sûreté
nucléaire j'ai demandé à l'IRSN de se
pencher sur le sujet de l'entreposage à
sec
des déchets nucléaires
ils l'ont fait ils m'ont fait un très
bon rapport qu'ils ont dû faire en un
temps assez court puisque puisque
c'était en deux mois je crois donc
c'était très court mais ils ont pu
poursuivre ce rapport justement quand la
CNDP les a saisissent c'est pour ça que
je me souviens que c'est sur les déchets
puisque c'était dans la suite
ce rapport a permis de dire que
l'entreposage pouvait être une solution
d'autres usage à sec vous pouvez être
une solution pour gérer un certain
nombre de déchets face aux problèmes que
nous avons aujourd'hui de saturation des
piscines
et notamment des saturations à la Hague
ils ont permis de faire des
modélisations sur des déchets entre
guillemets traditionnels et puis sur les
déchets un peu plus compliqué à gérer
que sont par exemple les MOX et les
moxusés ce travail là n'était pas dans
le SCOP de de ce que la SN avait demandé
à faire à l'IRSN je le sais puisque
quand j'en ai parlé à jean-christ on
avait jamais été saisi sur ça c'est
intéressant etc
je ne crois pas que on pourrait faire ça
mais encore une fois on parle en théorie
dans un monde avec des sites et
d'hypothèse puisque on ne sait rien là
de ce qui se passe mais en tout cas dans
le cadre d'une fusion ce genre de choses
serait beaucoup plus difficile or
ces deux rapports puisqu'il y en a deux
ont été extrêmement utiles pour avancer
sur la la réflexion que nous avons tous
sur la gestion des déchets radioactif
dans notre pays donc vous voyez voilà un
exemple merci pour cet exemple concret
mais alors justement qu'est-ce qui à
part les moyens s'ils étaient pas
diminués qu'est-ce qui empêcherait les
SN de répondre à ce type de commande si
ces moyens étaient préservés simplement
en étant regroupés dans une entité plus
large
pardon
je vous retourne la question pourquoi
est-ce que l'ASM demande ça
pourquoi l'ASN parce qu'on sait enfin
j'ai pas de confirmation mais c'est pour
moi une évidence que cette demande vient
de la SN pourquoi la SN demande à avoir
l'IRSN dans son giron
si c'est pour si c'est pas pour
justement avoir l'IRSN à sa disposition
beaucoup plus que maintenant moi je ne
vois pas d'autres raisons
et encore une fois je loin de moi l'idée
d'interférer et d'empêcher la SN de
faire son travail qui est nécessaire et
qui est du bon travail mais est-ce que
c'est forcément avec cette solution là
que ce sera mieux je moi j'ai vraiment
des doutes mais encore une fois
on verra je
parle on parle en théorie il paraît
qu'il va y avoir une mission de
préfiguration qui va être faite je crois
bah voyons voir ce que va donner cette
mission mais en tout cas une mission de
préfiguration ça peut pas
faire que ce sujet soit réglé au détour
d'un amendement dans une loi
justement pour finir sur la sûreté je
reviens parce que en plus vous l'avez
cité sur la commission d'enquête pardon
vous étiez là la rapporteur sur
l'expertise
vous vous auditionnez un certain nombre
de personnes dont d'audition dont vous
rendez compte à la fois dans les comptes
rendus et puis bien sûr dans dans le
rapport et un certain nombre d'experts
que vous auditionnez dont un d'ailleurs
je crois monsieur Marignac qu'on a
auditionné
récemment parle je cite d'une forme
d'endogamie de l'expertise d'un entre
soi ce qui vous conduit un certain
nombre de préconisations dont une que je
lis rapidement favoriser la présence
d'experts non institutionnel au sein
d'organismes tels que la SN l'IRSN
landra de manière réduire l'entre-soi
entre guillemets des techniciens mis en
évidence au cours des auditions
rémunérer la participation des experts
indépendants à ces instants puisque
notamment monsieur Mérignac dit que la
difficulté que les experts indépendants
non institutionnels ne soient pas
rémunéré c'est que on est à faire je
cite ces mots à des militants engagés
qui prennent du temps mais qui n'ont pas
les moyens à disposition pour faire
cette expertise est-ce que quand vous
avez mené cette position d'enquête vous
avez eu l'impression que l'expertise
française était insuffisamment robuste
au point de faire cette préconisation de
dire que finalement il y avait une
endogamie et qu'en fait
les experts institutionnels je sais pas
exactement ce que vous mettez derrière
ce mot mais que les experts
institutionnels n'étaient pas assez
compétents libres ou indépendant pour
mener leur mission à bien
non c'est un sujet compliqué parce que
en fait
on se rend compte que par la force des
choses
parce que l'énergie nucléaire c'est un
sujet complexe un sujet technique même
si ce n'est pas pour ça qui doit être
confié par les techniciens et ça je me
suis toujours élevé contre ça parce que
les techniciens les politiques sont pas
forcément des bons techniciens mais
alors les bons techniciens sont pas
forcément des bons politiques non plus
donc chacun a sa place
le problème c'est que on s'est rendu
compte que ceux qui s'occupent du
nucléaire que ce soit ceux qui sont chez
les
producteurs d'énergie donc les
constructeurs de centrales etc
sont formés sont les mêmes que ceux qui
font des expertises par définition ils
sont allés dans les mêmes écoles ils se
connaissent
c'est un petit monde de monde du
nucléaire c'est un monde où tout le
monde se connaît d'ailleurs y compris
les experts indépendants ils connaissent
tous ils se connaissent tous et donc
c'est un monde dans lequel il faut faire
attention à
ne pas être
un petit peu dans son dans sa petite
bulle et c'est ce que disait je pense
que c'est ce que voulait dire Yves
Marignac quand il a quand il a exprimé
ça c'est que il y a un besoin de pouvoir
faire venir
en fait le plus possible des experts qui
soient pas forcément de cette bulle là
et qui puisse intervenir sauf que pour
qu'il puisse intervenir il faut qu'ils
aient moyen de le faire les experts qui
sont je veux pas dire de bêtises mais de
mémoire les experts qui étaient
sollicités par la SN par exemple j'étais
pas payé était même pas je suis même pas
sûr qu'ils étaient défrayés donc
évidemment ça posait un certain nombre
de problèmes et pour que le monde du
nucléaire sorte de l'entre-soi il y a un
besoin de l'ouvrir et de l'ouvrir y
compris à des experts en organisation à
des experts qui soient pas forcément des
experts techniques sur comment
fonctionne l'atome
on l'a vu dans ce dans cette commission
d'enquête on avait des vrais problèmes
avec la sous-traitance
et pas seulement avec la compétence des
sous-traitants mais avec la manière dont
les sous-traitances en cascade générer
des pertes de responsabilité de
responsabilisation des uns et des autres
et pouvait entraîner des problèmes de
sûreté vous voyez bien que là on n'est
pas dans des problèmes stricto sensuels
nucléaires mais qui pourtant entraîne
des problèmes de sûreté et l'ASN doit
pouvoir avoir affaire à des spécialistes
qui sont des spécialistes aussi
qui qui regarde comme ça ces modes de
fonctionnement qui peuvent entraîner des
problèmes voilà je pense que et puis en
plus il faut aussi que il puisse y avoir
des des
visions différentes qui puissent
s'exprimer c'est très important parce
que quand on est dans la pensée unique
on n'avance pas on n'est pas bon et on
peut passer à côté de problème parce
qu'on est on n'a pas de point de vue
différents qui s'exprime
je vous remercie une sur ce sujet là
peut-être une question plus large qui
s'adresse aussi à l'ancienne présidente
de la commission du développement
durable sur
le niveau d'information du Parlement à
la fois en matière de sûreté nucléaire
mais plus largement de connaissances des
enjeux énergétiques et du besoin ou pas
selon vous
que ce débat soit plus mieux informé de
la part des autorités indépendantes du
gouvernement
institutionnalisé peut-être aussi de
manière diverse pour que en amont des
lois qui sont votées et vous avez évoqué
le changement majeur avec le vote d'une
noix de programmation énergies climat
pour que le Parlement soit très bien
investi en partent informés en
particulier la commission de
développement durable qui au moins pour
avis et saisie sur les questions
énergétiques
tout à fait
pas que pour avis parce que les
centrales nucléaires c'est de la
compétence des
en fait la politique énergétique est
plutôt de la compétence des affaires
économiques mais par contre les
installations sont ça c'est la magie de
des découpages de
compétences des commissions qui posent
des problèmes par ailleurs mais bon ça
c'est autre chose
on l'avait dit dans notre rapport de
commission d'enquête
il y a un problème d'association des
parlementaires à
[Musique]
au fonctionnement de de notre de notre
système nucléaire
pourquoi parce que d'abord
c'est pas facile pour le monde nucléaire
de s'ouvrir
à d'ouvrir d'ouvrir son fonctionnement à
des parlementaires bon on a été très
bien reçus pendant la commission
d'enquête il y a pas eu de problème mais
à partir du moment où pour beaucoup
c'est une question de spécialiste on va
quand même pas aller
demander à des parlementaires de ce
substituer à des spécialistes et
risqueraient de faire des bêtises
il y a un autre sujet c'est que sur les
questions de sûreté nous c'était sûreté
et sécurité donc je rappelle pour
mémoire à tout le monde que la sûreté
nucléaire c'est
la gestion en fait de du bon
fonctionnement des installations et de
leur résistance aux différents aléas
notamment des aléas naturels comment une
centrale nucléaire fait face à un
événement climatique à une inondation un
tremblement de terre
est-ce qu'elle est assez résistante pour
voilà c'est ça la question de la sûreté
c'est est-ce que
[Musique]
la centrale est résistante en termes de
fonctionnement normal et après la
question de la sécurité là c'est
comment réagit une centrale un réacteur
un site par rapport à des agressions
extérieures donc on a tous en tête
une agression terroriste par exemple
ou un avion enfin et où un avion qui
tombe sur une centrale ou des drones on
avait été confrontés à des problèmes de
drone qui rentraient dans dans les
dans les sites nucléaires comment on
résiste face à la cybercriminalité qui
est un sujet très très important comment
les centrales peuvent résister face à
tout ça et autant sur les questions de
sûreté on a eu accès à tous les éléments
la SN publie des rapports très
régulièrement on a eu vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments de manière assez
précise autant sur la sécurité on nous a
opposé le secret défense à de très
nombreuses reprises et d'ailleurs
parfois de manière un peu bizarre je
vous donne un exemple qui montre à quel
point d'ailleurs la sécurité c'est un
peu
sa géométrie variable il faut savoir que
le secret défense enfin moi j'ai
découvert à ce moment-là c'est le
l'opérateur qui décide de ce qui est
secret défense et de ce qui ne l'est pas
et donc nous on avait une réflexion sur
la sûreté des piscines la sécurité des
piscines d'entreposage des des
combustibles
usés et donc il y avait sur les sites à
côté des réacteurs et puis il y avait à
lag les sites des centrales c'était EDF
lag c'était Orano
et bien nous avons demandé à EDF et
Orano de nous produire les plans des
piscines
EDF
nous a opposé le secret défense Orano
nous a donné les plans enfin nous en
tout cas nous a pas donné mais nous les
a fait consulter nous avons pu consulter
les plans des piscines d'entreposage de
lag qui sont pourtant pour le coup des
sites enfin extrêmement sensible c'est
un peu pas et donc
vous voyez il y a un sujet c'est en fait
c'est EDF et Orano qui décidait ce que
les parlementaires avaient le droit de
voir ou pas
et je trouve ça extrêmement choquant
nous sommes les représentants du peuple
on doit pouvoir avoir les moyens de
d'avoir accès à ces informations et
c'est pour ça que une des préconisations
qui n'a pas été suivie des faits de
notre commission d'enquête ce que je
regrette beaucoup était de créer une
délégation au nucléaire sur le mot sur
le modèle de la délégation au
renseignement pourquoi parce que on peut
comprendre que
que des éléments secrets défenses soient
pas répandus sur la place publique
surtout quand ça concerne la sécurité
des installations nucléaires on est sur
des domaines très sensibles donc pas de
sujet c'est normal que ça soit pas
répandue partout mais par contre qui est
une délégation avec des personnes
membres de cette des députés des
sénateurs des parlementaires membres de
ces délégations qui de fait de
l'appartenance à cette Commission puisse
avoir une habilitation secrète défense
pour aller voir ce qui est ce qui ce
qu'il en est je pense que c'était très
important et c'est dommage que on n'est
pas mis en place je le regrette beaucoup
parce que du coup je suis désolé mais
moi quand je vote en tant que
parlementaire les le budget de la
défense de la sécurité nucléaire de mon
pays je ne sais pas ce que je veux
et ça me gêne et donc que on est une
délégation qui puisse faire le travail
de vérification et qui puisse après dire
au collègues ok nous on a vérifié ça
roule ça roule pas
là moi j'ai demandé est-ce que des
missiles qu'on peut trouver sur les
sites des guerres qu'on peut sont
peuvent transpercer les murs des
bâtiments piscine
à côté des réacteurs
on m'a dit oui oui c'est bon on a fait
l'expérience ça va
faites-nous confiance
mon rôle en tant que parlementaire c'est
pas de faire confiance mon rôle en tant
que parlementaire c'est de contrôler de
vérifier je n'ai pas les moyens de
contrôler de vérifier aujourd'hui et je
pense que c'est un problème et donc si
par hasard même si vous n'êtes pas
exactement sur le sujet vous pouviez
relancer cette idée de délégation je
vous appuierais très fortement
merci le rapporteur entend le rapporteur
j'en viens justement à une question à
votre arrivée aux responsabilités en
tant que ministre de la transition
écologique en juillet 2020 donc en plein
covid en pleine crise juste après le
la première phase
se pose j'imagine que vous rencontrez
très rapidement EDF et que ce se pose
l'ensemble des questions enfin en tout
cas dans les premiers dans les tous
premiers entretiens vous avez les
discussions sur les ensembles de
l'ensemble des questions qui se posent
là maintenant le renouvellement l'état
des compétences et d'ailleurs je
viendrai peut-être après mais il y a un
comité de filière qui se réunit un an
après où vous lancez un certain nombre
d'initiatives pour relancer la question
et compétences quand vous avez ces
premiers entretiens quel quel sentiment
vous avez de l'état de l'entreprise EDF
de la performance de son parc de sa
capacité à le maintenir et puis est-ce
que le calendrier dès maintenant ça a
déjà commencé à être déc des organisé
comme DFA pu nous l'expliquer est-ce que
vous avez des discussions pour anticiper
au maximum ces retards est-ce que et
j'ajoute pardon une question ça fait
beaucoup mais puisque RTE a déjà indiqué
que le l'hiver 2022 2023 était un hiver
sensible est-ce que c'est déjà quelque
chose qui est dans la discussion de se
dire est-ce que le décalage de ces
maintenant se peut avoir un impact
important sur l'hiver 2022 2023 enfin
pardon pour la vasté de la question mais
vous voyez ce que je veux dire non c'est
assez simple le problème avec EDF
évidemment on se rend compte très vite
on a un certain nombre de sujets à
développer je me souviens à l'époque
aussi que un des sujets c'était la
centrale de larrivo parce qu'on parle
toujours de l'électricité en France
métropolitaine mais on parle pas de ce
qui se passe dans les outre-mer et à
l'époque dans les outre-mer
personne ne trouvait à redire y compris
mes prédécesseurs
au fait qu'on allait construire une
centrale à fioul
neuve une centrale à fioul dans un
territoire d'outre-mer
voilà je suis arrivé voilà donc c'est un
des voyants c'est un des premiers sujets
que j'ai abordé avec EDF
parce que je
leur expliquais que ça allait pas être
possible et donc ça a un peu paniqué
tout le monde et on a fini par trouver
une solution comme quoi
comme quoi on finit toujours quand on
essaye de s'y mettre le problème avec
EDF et
c'est vraiment un problème pénible à
gérer quand on est en responsabilité
c'est que on soulève tous les problèmes
les uns après les autres donc évidemment
on avait déjà le problème du calendrier
de maintenance
on savait pas que ça allait prendre une
telle envergure mais à l'époque on
savait déjà que il y avait un problème
de de décalage de la maintenance il y
avait le problème de Flamanville
et les soudures s'ils étaient déjà
c'était déjà
on avait
le bon problème des renouvelables n'en
parle pas et puis et puis cette question
de est-ce qu'il fallait ou pas
construire les nouveaux réacteurs
et on avait un problème avec EDF c'est
que à chaque fois qu'on lui disait
est-ce que il y a un problème il disait
non non non tout va bien
donc les maintenant c'est bon ça va être
réglé
Flamanville oui non c'est bon ça va être
réglé donc c'était tout le temps ça et
par contre alors que vous aviez déjà eu
le rapport fold ça avait déjà été publié
mais
c'est toujours mais on va
on est en train de réparer mais en gros
clairement
[Musique]
alors est-ce que c'était lié à ma
personnalité ou pas mais je ne pense pas
je ne pense pas
c'était tout va très bien Madame le
marquise mais du coup qui au ministère
par exemple un exemple concret
flamant ville 3 chantier de LEPR qui au
ministère suit de façon technique ce
dossier comment est-ce que le ministère
suit ce dossier parce que qu'on se fasse
balader par EDF je comprends que ça
puisse être désagréable mais quelle est
la réponse de l'administration
à laquelle à la tête laquelle vous avez
été un moment donné pour s'assurer de la
vraie semblabilité des informations qui
viennent d'EDF
on a on a
l'administration du ministère qui en
charge c'est la DGEC donc c'est la
direction générale de l'énergie du
climat qui elle-même a une direction qui
s'appelle la direction de l'énergie qui
est menée de maintenir par Sophie
Mourlon qui est une
administratrice extrêmement compétente
sur le sujet qui représente d'ailleurs
l'État au Conseil des ministration d'EDF
donc on a on a un contrôle on a la SN
évidemment qui qui surveille aussi la SN
fait son travail y compris sur sur le
chantier sur le chantier de Flamanville
mais après c'est un chantier en cours
donc
on nous donne c'est comme c'est comme
pour tout chantier en fait vous avez un
calendrier mais on dira pourquoi le
calendrier ça marche pas bah là on a
donc là c'était le problème des soudures
ben donc là on a fait un plan pour
définir qu'est-ce qu'on allait faire sur
ces soudures ce plan est validé ou pas
par la SN donc le plan est soumis à la
SN puisque il y a toujours une question
de sûreté nucléaire donc là sur les
soudures il y avait enfin je vous
rappelle qu'on parle de soudure qui
était entre deux parois d'un mur
d'enceinte d'un d'un réacteur puisque
c'était un réacteur c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui a enfin c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle on va plus avoir de double
mur
danse de l'EPR donc c'est un double mur
un double mur d'enceinte et les tuyaux
dont on parlait où il y avait des
problèmes de soudure ils étaient enfin
il y en avait au milieu là et donc en
gros soit on détruisait tout autour pour
aller atteindre les soudures soit en
trouver d'autres solutions donc ils ont
travaillé à proposer des solutions ils
ont proposé des solutions qui ont été
expertisé par Dyson la SN un moment a
dit ok feu vert pour cette solution là
après ils ont commencé à lancer la
solution et donc pendant ce temps-là les
semaines et les mois passent donc c'est
comme ça que ça se passe donc c'est un
peu compliqué sur le calendrier de
maintenance on nous envoie des
calendriers
et c'est pour ça qu'à la fin j'ai
commencé à m'énerver un an plus tard en
disant vous nous envoyez des calendriers
mais bon enfin où en est-on quid voilà
donc c'est
quand ça part dans je me permets
simplement de vous pour pouvoir relancer
ce point-là que vous parlez des retards
et du décalage un peu perpétuel en tout
cas sous votre mandat quels étaient les
raisons avancées est-ce que elles
évoluent avec le temps est-ce que
c'était la question de la compétence de
la disponibilité de la main d'oeuvre
est-ce qu'il y avait d'autres raisons
avancées
quand on nous donnait des raisons
je vous rappelle que il y a un truc dont
on a pas du tout parlé mais qui est
aussi en l'air à ce moment-là c'est la
et ça je m'en souviens parce que ça a
été un des premiers rendez-vous que j'ai
eu avec EDF on a parlé de ça c'était la
réforme d'EDF
vous savez qu'il y avait aussi le projet
de réforme d'EDF qui est lié d'ailleurs
aussi à toute la question de la de la
fin de la reine en 2025 et donc ce sujet
là étaient aussi sur la table et donc il
y avait aussi les problèmes des
syndicats qui s'inquiétaient beaucoup
sur cela il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes organisationnels autour de
cette réforme de DF qui était qui était
en chantier
mais après pour le reste les raisons
qu'on nous donnait alors une raison qui
a avancé tout le temps par EDF pour
expliquer les problèmes qu'ils ont
rencontrés que ce soit sur la
maintenance que ce soit sur sur le site
de Flamanville c'est le problème de
manque de compétences qui est liée selon
eux au fait que comme il n'y a pas eu de
vrai politique de relance du nucléaire
dans notre pays
et bien il n'arrivait plus à trouver des
personnels compétents ça c'est la
réponse à chaque fois que il y a un
problème il me dit bah nous on a perdu
en compétences parce que on n'a pas pu
en gros construire au fur et à mesure
des nouvelles centrales des nouveaux
réacteurs donc maintenant bah voilà le
résultat c'est de votre faute je trouve
que c'est une manière un petit peu
facile
de repousser la faute sur sur les
politiques qui ont leur part mais
je trouve que c'est facile
merci ça planche reprend le bout de ma
dernière question sur la manière dont
connaissances et retard et le décalage
progressif vous anticipez vous posez la
question de l'hiver 2022-2023
je peux plus vous dire si je l'ai posé à
ce moment-là mais il est fort probable
que je l'ai posé il est fort probable
qu'on m'a dit qu'il y aura pas tout va
bien
fort probable je vous remercie avant de
passer la collecte de la parole
simplement quand même une question alors
pas proportionnelle à l'importance qu'on
y apporte parce que la question est un
peu dense mais sur les énergies
renouvelables
pour avoir votre sentiment de
parlementaire président de la Commission
de développement durable ministre puis à
nouveau parlementaire qu'un sujet que
vous avez évidemment suivi au plus haut
point et au plus haut niveau en portant
des mesures d'accélération mais aussi en
portant des mesures j'allais dire de
compensation environnementale ou en tout
cas d'acceptabilité sociale et
environnementale le Parlement a
récemment adopté une loi une nouvelle
loi d'accélération sur les énergies
renouvelables
je pense que là on a quand même pas mal
déblayé
on a pas mal déblayé maintenant
je pense que ce qui bloque vraiment sur
le développement des énergies
renouvelables
c'est que
on l'a pas pris par le bon bout et
encore une fois j'en reviens au problème
originels de du fait que les énergies
renouvelables ont été construites comme
quelque chose qui était contre le
nucléaire et à partir de ce moment là ça
a faussé le débat et ça a empêché de
travailler là dessus or on le voit
partout
les énergies renouvelables sont de moins
en moins chères sont de plus en plus
intéressantes d'un point de vue
économique et se développe partout dans
le monde tous les scénarios qui sont
faites par les institutions
internationales que ce soit l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie que ce soit
l'iréna bien évidemment ou autre disent
que les énergies renouvelables seront
l'avenir de l'énergie dans le monde
entier si on veut atteindre nos
objectifs de d'accord de Paris
trouve que en France on continue à le
regarder par le prisme de
des paysages et de la teinte à la
biodiversité
certainement il y a un travail à faire
pour que les gens s'approprient ce sujet
c'est pour ça que j'avais beaucoup
développé les communautés d'énergies
renouvelables qui avaient été lancées
avant que j'arrive mais dont je pense
que il faut les
qu'il faut les développer plus pourquoi
parce que ça permet aux gens d'être
acteur du développement de leur
politique énergétique et c'est pas rien
sur des sujets notamment comme l'éolien
terrestres parce que sur l'éolien
terrestre quand vous avez un
un parc éolien à côté de chez vous
c'est très différent si c'est porté par
une grosse boîte
que vous ne connaissez pas et qui ne
sera pas là pour répondre à vos
questions pour résoudre les problèmes si
vous si vous en avez et si c'est porté
par une association par la collectivité
ou par une boîte beaucoup plus locale
qui le jour où il y a le moindre
problème qui sera là et du coup on
revient à quelque chose qui
qui est beaucoup plus justement à
échelle humaine et beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus intéressant donc je dis
pas qu'il faut que ça je dis que par
contre c'est un beau vecteur
d'acceptabilité le deuxième vecteur
d'acceptabilité c'est de savoir où on va
là je pense que moi qui suis d'un
département où on a développé beaucoup
d'éoliennes
beaucoup de gens me disaient oh là là
mais en fait on ne sait pas quand ça va
s'arrêter on a l'impression qu'il y en a
une qui pousse une autre qui pousse
partout on sait pas comment donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a essayé de développer une
planification sur ce sujet
dont on a mis beaucoup de germes dans la
loi climatilian en demandant en créant
les communautés régionales de l'énergie
face c'est plus ça s'appelle pas une
communauté
enfin
vous retrouverez le terme exact mais qui
permettent en fait à tous les
responsables et les acteurs de se mettre
autour de la table et de dire voilà nous
on a tel objectif à remplir en termes de
de puissance installée d'énergie
renouvelable voilà nous comment on va
proposer de le faire et comment on va
proposer de le mettre en oeuvre en
utilisant tel ou tel type d'énergie
renouvelable et donc ça permet aussi aux
acteurs de terrain d'être les acteurs de
la transition écologique sur leur
territoire
avec l'État qui est là pour donner les
grandes lignes et les grandes directions
je pense que c'est important que les
gens se réapproprient en fait le
développement de leur territoire et il
faut aussi que les gens se réapproprient
l'idée que on est en train de changer de
monde que l'énergie qu'on dépensé avant
c'était beaucoup d'énergie fossiles
alors effectivement on la voyait pas on
voyait pas d'où elle venait parce que
les puits de pétrole ils étaient pas
chez nous parce que les champs de gaz
ils étaient pas chez nous et que si on
veut les remplacer par de l'énergie
décarbonée et qu'on veut localiser et
ben ça va se voir moi je viens du
bassinier du Nord-Pas-de-Calais je peux
vous dire je sais ce que c'est qu'un
paysage qui a été modelé par une
industrie et par par une époque on entre
dans une nouvelle époque croire ou faire
vouloir croire que cette époque ne se
verra pas dans notre environnement ça
n'a pas de sens et donc il faut aussi
accepter l'idée que ça va se voir et que
si on veut avoir de l'énergie ça se voit
c'est pas un grave je pense que ça
s'encadre il faut faire attention de ne
pas faire n'importe quoi on a fait dans
la loi et dans des mesures que j'ai
prises
en lien avec la filière je parle surtout
là de l'éolien on sort mais c'est pareil
pour les olives Shore et puis c'est pas
pareil aussi pour le photovoltaïque on a
fait mis en place avec la filière des
mesures pour faire en sorte de prendre
en compte les paysages remarquables de
prendre en compte la biodiversité parce
qu'il peut y avoir localement des
atteintes adap biodiversité ce qui
serait quand même dommage donc même si
je rappelle que une des causes les plus
importantes de la paire de biodiversité
c'est le changement climatique donc les
énergies renouvelables font partie de la
solution voilà c'est un changement
d'état d'esprit et puis c'est aussi
éviter les bêtises qui ont pu être
faites par le passé et qui ont été
réelles
je remercie pour vos réponses et sans
autre passer les droits constitutionnels
et du Règlement je sais que la parole à
mon collègue tu vois
merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre donc je reviendrai
sur vos propos et j'aurais donc au moins
trois questions la première donc vous
nous dites en préambule que sur les mix
donc vous pensez qu'un mixte à 100% ENR
à l'horizon 2050 et viable donc je
voudrais que vous vous déployer sur
quelle mesure surtout que
tout le monde est bien conscient que
pour que ce soit fiable surtout il faut
une complémentarité au niveau des
différentes énergies et comment et ben
dans ce mix 100% ENR on peut avoir cette
complémentarité
les autres questions seraient sur donc
vous nous parlez
que il manque il faut que les objectifs
soient claires et vous nous dites
avant le discours de du 10 février de
2022 discours de Belfort donc il
manquait un pilote
et notamment vous avez dit que dans ce
discours il y a trois piliers
qui sont clairs la relance du nucléaire
le développement des énergies
renouvelables et la baisse de
consommation la sobriété
il manquait un pilote alors moi je le
prenais pas mal mais vous êtes bénie de
2020 2022 jusqu'au discours de Belfort
donc il y avait pas de pilote au niveau
du de la transition écologique et
transition énergétique
et sur l'ensemble des experts monsieur
bréchet du CEA en 2018 remet un rapport
donc en précisant bien que et avec et le
président des DF nous le confirme aussi
monsieur Broglio donc en nous disant que
vous étiez prévenu monsieur bréchet même
au-delà de ça il dit quand je remets mon
rapport la prochaine fois j'avais un
remède je le relirai des deux côtés
parce que au moins j'aurai la certitude
qu'il a pas été lu
et
spécifie tout comme Monsieur Proglio en
nous disant que vous aviez à votre
connaissance dès 2018
qu'il ne fallait surtout pas fermer de
réacteurs avant d'ouvrir Flamanville
puisque on risquait de perdre notre
souveraineté électrique pourtant donc le
22 février 2020 vous arrêtez donc le
réacteur de affessenheim le premier
réacteur et le 30 juin donc le deuxième
réacteur
et suite il que ça mais ça accélère
sûrement donc notre perte de
souveraineté électrique
sur ensuite les énergies renouvelables
donc la place de l'hydroélectricité on
sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est 49 % que c'est
extrêmement important c'est la seule
façon qu'on a de stocker
l'hydroélectricité
nous avons auditionné j'ai
personnellement auditionné donc le
responsable donc de l'hydroélectricité
du Massif central et Bretagne qui nous
dit avoir donc la possibilité de mettre
5 gigawatts donc en suréquipement
notamment en step et de turbinets donc
les débits réservés et certains débits
qui sont donc sur des conduites forcées
encore pas turbinet qui n'ont aucune
incidence sur la biodiversité
et ça représente 5 tranches nucléaires
et on sent bien que dans vos propos
quand vous parlez d'énergie renouvelable
vous en avez parlé effectivement de
d'éolien offshore vous avez parlé de de
photovoltaïques et on sent bien de
biogaz également mais jamais un mot sur
l'hydroélectricité et la question c'est
comment je comprends que vous soyez en
colère vous l'avez dit après EDF à
certains moments mais on sait très bien
que sur ce mix et j'aimerais vous poser
la dernière question sur quel est le
mixte le mixte qu'on pourrait prévoir et
sur un temps long je crois qu'il
faudrait que on arrive à se décider dans
cette fameuse et vous l'avez dit que
la loi qui devrait être votée donc en
2023 par nous-mêmes par nous tous
permettra donc de se projeter sauf que
tout le monde
nous dit bien et on en est conscient que
long c'est des temps d'investissement
donc comment se projeter et les
industriels puissent se projeter alors
que aujourd'hui on est même pas clair
sur ce mix et est-ce qu'il sera
réellement gravé dans le marbre et à
chaque alternance politique si ce mixe
doit évoluer comment voulez-vous que les
industriels se positionnent et est-ce
que dans ce cette fameuse loi on pourra
en saura se positionner les uns les
autres et surtout les scènes aux
industriels cette possibilité de temps
long et qui nous permettra certainement
d'avoir notre de garder notre
souveraineté merci pour la réponse
merci beaucoup alors d'abord sur sur le
mix 100% NR
encore une fois moi je reste à ma place
je laisse faire ce les experts et je
regarde ce qui leurs expertises
vous avez pour la France et pour les
autres pays c'est pas tout à fait pareil
parce qu'on n'a pas le même mix il faut
regarder pays par pays
pour la France on sait que on peut avoir
un mix 100%
énergies renouvelables en 2050 mais que
c'est quelque chose qui demande
énormément d'efforts ça demande des
efforts et ça encore une fois c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est dans les rapports
ça demande beaucoup de travail d'efforts
en termes de sobriété donc en termes de
de
d'économie d'énergie
ça demande un énorme travail sur les
réseaux ça demande un énorme travail sur
le stockage et donc faire aussi des
évolutions sur le stockage dont
certaines on les a pas aujourd'hui ça
demande d'avoir une bonne
complémentarité entre les énergies mais
bon ça c'est pas si compliqué que ça en
fait c'est ce que vous diront beaucoup
d'ingénieurs sur l'électricité ils
disent vous savez
en fait on passe notre vie en fait à
faire rentrer tel type d'électricité
sortir tactique d'électricité
importer l'électricité en quasiment
heure par heure donc c'est des choses
qui se pilotent donc le problème n'est
pas tant là que sur le fait que comme on
a comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
comme on a perdu beaucoup de temps sur
le développement des renouvelables dans
notre pays aujourd'hui pour arriver à ce
résultat dans un laps de temps qui est
du coup plus court
avec un parc nucléaire qui est
vieillissant
même moi qui suis plutôt favorable par a
priori à cette solution même moi je
pense que c'est risqué que c'est risqué
notamment parce que ça veut dire que
pour pouvoir faire cette transition on
doit garder le parc nucléaire actuel
longtemps puisque dans cette hypothèse
là on ne fait pas de nouveau réacteurs
et donc le garder de plus longtemps
possible et tirer
vu les déconvenues que j'ai pu avoir
quand j'étais ministre sur l'état d'un
certain nombre de
d'installations je pense que c'est
prendre un postulat qui est quand même
qui est risqué c'est-à-dire que si on a
un problème sur notre parc de réacteurs
nucléaire et qu'on n'a rien d'autre
il faut
voilà
c'est pour ça que je me sens assez à
l'aise avec le discours de Belfort même
si pour en toute franchise
le discours de Belfort parle de 6 plus 8
réacteurs je pense que si ce sera déjà
ça voilà un monde à mon opinion c'est
que je pense qu'on peut faire sans 114
mais bon après c'est le président qui a
donné sa vision et ça c'est tout à fait
normal sur la question il y a-t-il un
pilote j'ai expliqué ce que je voulais
dire
quand je dis il y a-t-il un pilote
c'est-à-dire y a-t-il quelqu'un qui
tient la barre pour que ça pour qu'on
aille qu'on fasse ce qu'on a dit je
persiste à dire que on n'a pas
suffisamment pour plein de raisons
mis les moyens pour arriver à faire ce
qu'on a dit
voilà et que ce soit pour les fermetures
de réacteurs et j'expliquais pourquoi
que ce soit pour le développement des
renouvelables je pense que il y a eu une
certaine
retenue parce que quelque part il y
avait pas de vision claire et donc quand
on dit pas de pilote c'est que à un
moment encore une fois quand on est dans
le brouillard on avance pas vite et ben
on était embrouillard et à un moment il
fallait sortir du brouillard que le
choix fait nous plaise ou pas après ça
c'est des choix politiques sur
sur Fessenheim sur le rapport de 2018
moi j'étais pas au gouvernement ni au
moment de la remise du rapport ni au
moment de la fermeture de Fessenheim
donc moi j'ai pas eu ces éléments là
dans les mains donc je peux pas trop les
commenter par contre je peux vous dire
une chose c'est que
encore une fois je rappelle que tout ça
y compris la fermeture de Fessenheim a
été mis en place à l'époque où EDF nous
disait mais le Pr ça fait longtemps
qu'il sera mis en marche
le problème aussi c'est que à chaque
fois EDF nous disait que ça marchait
donc on mettait en place des politiques
qui tenaient compte de ce que nous
disait EDF
aussi
je veux pas dire que l'élève est
responsable de tout mais je veux dire
que là dessus
quand vous avez à préparer un territoire
à préparer le territoire sur lequel
était implanté la centrale nucléaire de
Fessenheim préparer les travailleurs
préparés des reconversions préparé une
vous pouvez pas faire ça comme ça du
jour au lendemain vous avez besoin
d'anticiper vous avez besoin d'avoir un
calendrier vous avez besoin d'avoir les
gens ce projet les gens se disent fais
vous bossez la centrale vous pouvez pas
sans arrêt vous dire bon bah en fait
j'arrête de travailler l'année prochaine
ah bah non finalement c'est encore
l'année prochaine après non moi je
considère que c'est c'est irresponsable
de laisser les gens comme ça dans la de
dans le la plus totale
inquiétude dans le fait de pas savoir
ils peuvent pas se projeter ils peuvent
rien organiser donc c'est pour ça que je
trouve normal et là j'y étais pas au
gouvernement mais je vous donne mon
opinion je trouve normal que à un moment
à partir du moment où la décision de
fermer Fessenheim était prise depuis
longtemps ce qui fait que d'ailleurs
les travaux de sûreté qui aurait dû être
pris si Fessenheim continuer n'avait pas
été fait la dernière visite décennale
n'avait pas été faite donc on avait
rendu le truc
du fait que ces visites n'avaient pas
été faites et c'était devenu une
éducable donc ça allait fermer à un
moment enfin les sonner la fin de la
récré fallait ne serait-ce que par
respect vis-à-vis des gens qui
travaillaient sur place stop quoi
maintenant on va pas attendre que le
père de Flamanville soit en
fonctionnement parce que sinon on laisse
ces gens ne pas pouvoir se projeter
pendant des années donc c'est normal je
pense que on est fermé Fessenheim et que
ça a été et que ça a été fait alors
effectivement pendant ce temps là les
1,6 gigawatts n'étaient pas là
est-ce que c'est pour ça que ça que
notre système a été mis en danger enfin
en tout cas en difficulté notre système
électrique non non et non
les problèmes qu'on avait il a des
réacteurs qui étaient fermés c'était on
avait 30 réacteur à un moment qui a été
fermé 30 réacteurs 30 réacteurs c'est en
grossissant énormément c'est 30 GW
de puissance installée
Fessenheim c'était deux
donc c'est pas ça le problème enfin il
faut vraiment satisfaite à faire de
Fessenheim qui a été monté en épingle
c'est pas ça le problème si on avait que
le problème de Fessenheim de gigawatt ça
se trouve
sur l'hydroélectricité pour aller plus
vite sur l'hydroélectricité je n'en ai
pas parlé pas parce que ce n'est pas
important je pense que évidemment c'est
très important c'est une grosse part de
notre approvisionnement électricité on
est bien content de les avoir nos
barrages je peux vous dire
mais en termes de nouvelles filières
on considère que en réserve on a pu
énormément de choses donc c'est pour ça
que ça a pas été le cœur du
réacteur mais le cœur de de ce qu'on a
mis en place mais bien évidemment si les
steps peuvent être peuvent être utiles
peuvent être peuvent être utilisés ça
fait partie des choses qu'on a aussi
regardé je vous ai pas parlé non plus de
la géothermie je vous ai pas parlé d'un
certain nombre de choses après il y a
l'hydroélectricité il y a la
microhydroélectricité la micro
hydroélectricité peut être intéressante
sous réserve est toujours sous réserve
que il est pas de problème de continuité
écologique des cours d'eau parce que
sinon on oppose de problème donc à
regarder territoire par territoire mais
moi j'ai envie de vous dire
toutes les sources d'énergie doivent
être regardées et être utilisés à partir
du moment où elles peuvent l'être de
manière intelligente au regard des de
notre environnement on en a besoin
et se projeter c'est important je sais
plus pourquoi j'ai marqué ce projet
c'est important
vous avez parlé de ça sur les temps
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure
quand on est dans le brouillard on peut
pas avancer il faut donner des
perspectives là on se donne des
perspectives à 2050 et on se donne des
perspectives aussi sur
un trajet pour y arriver ce trajet il
devrait être rectifié mais en tout cas
là vous avez grâce à la programmation
plus réelle vous avez une programmation
sur 10 ans à chaque fois qui sont qui
sont à prix coupés en deux périodes de 5
ans donc là vous avez quand même une
possibilité pour les filières de se
projeter
au revoir monsieur le rapporteur
je vous en prie
notre président et notre rapporteur
mais j'espère que notre j'espère que
notre compagnie vous êtes agréable
évidemment voilà j'avais une question
aussi sur l'hydroélectricité depuis
plusieurs années la Commission
européenne nous sommes d'ouvrir la
concurrence
la gestion de nos ouvrages et donc les
concessions
dans le même délai de nombreux élus des
territoires
s'inquiètent de des effets que cela
pourrait produire notamment en matière
de démantèlement des chaînes
hydroélectriques
la question que je voulais vous poser
c'est c'est sur les deux années pour
lesquelles vous avez exercé cette
responsabilité au ministère qu'elles
initiatives ont été prises pour essayer
d'infléchir la position de la Commission
européenne est en entendue que il s'agit
bien d'une question pour le coup de
souveraineté
tout à fait
monsieur le député je
[Musique]
en fait ça a été un sujet qui était
présent un peu tout le temps
figurez-vous parce que
nous sommes très très
concernés par ça alors je peux vous
assurer d'une chose c'est que le
gouvernement
était très mobilisé justement pour
préserver nos
nos barrages hydroélectriques et pour
pour éviter que il y ait une forme
d'ouverture à la concurrence qui
qui nous prive d'une forme de
souveraineté sur ses barrages même si je
rappelle que c'est qu'on parle de
concession qu'on parle pas de
qu'on parle pas de possession
et donc pendant que j'étais en
responsabilité vous le savez il y avait
des négociations avec la Commission
européenne qui était des négociations
qui étaient globale et c'est ça en fait
le sujet c'est que il y avait une
demande de la Commission européenne de
effectivement d'avancer sur cette
question des
barrages puisque on est en infraction
avec la législation européenne depuis un
certain temps mais cette discussion
était clairement liée à la discussion
qui avait lieu par ailleurs sur EDF et
sur la sur la la
comment dire la réforme de DF et donc
pendant les deux ans où j'étais là les
discussions avancées par un coup sur ce
sujet là
avec d'ailleurs aussi dans le paysage la
reine et la fin de la reine et en fait
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que moi
quand je suis partie on avait toujours
pas abouti sur ces discussions là parce
que encore une fois tout était lié
et mais je serais je ne pourrais pas
vous donner beaucoup plus d'éléments que
ça parce que sur ces sujets là nous
avions décidé un partage des tâches avec
mon collègue Bruno Le Maire et puisque
vous savez que sur cette question de
l'organisation de DF on était on était
sur des compétences qui se chevauchaient
entre son ministère et le mien et à un
moment on s'était mis d'accord pour que
ce soit lui qui gère les négociations
donc il aurait beaucoup plus à vous
répondre que moi c'est à qui je
poursuivrai à qui je poserai la question
mais mais votre réponse est au demeurant
intéressante parce que la crainte que
l'on peut avoir effectivement c'est que
ce sujet de l'ouverture des concessions
soit
c'est pas la variable d'ajustement mais
puis cette victime d'une négociation
plus globale et puis cette laque j'ai
mon expression puisse être la concession
qu'on ferait à la Commission européenne
alors je comprends que vous puissiez
penser ça mais pour avoir quand même
vécu ça de l'intérieur c'est un peu
l'inverse enfin moi ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai vu c'est que cette question était
une question qui était
pas du tout considéré comme la variable
d'ajustement c'était un point fort dans
la négociation et il y avait une vraie
volonté de l'État de préserver nos
concessions
cette personne proportionnelle résultat
obtenu pour l'instant il y en a pas en
fait non mais oui mais pour l'instant il
y en a pas mais du coup du coup il n'y a
pas non plus de remise en concurrence
des concessions c'est ce que je peux
voir c'est que jusqu'à maintenant il y a
pas de remise en concurrence
des hommes très inconfortables y compris
d'ailleurs pour les exploitants et ça
rejoint la question de mon collègue avec
des des investissements qui sont
différés je suis d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que ça peut qu'il faut un moment
se sortir de ça
mais
pas vous dire plus que ça
moi j'en ai terminé
je sais pas qui revient là
responsabilité de conclure
[Musique]
et bien je vous remercie beaucoup
en l'absence on va considérer que
qu'on a épuisé l'ordre du jour les
participants aussi
je vous laisse merci à vous merci à vous